Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge numero? 47. 47. Wir wollen heute ein bisschen darüber reden, wie so Verschwörungstheorien gerade funktionieren, was das Problem mit der Wissenschaft ist, ihrer Wahrnehmung und wie man vielleicht versuchen kann, nicht irgendwie Pech zu haben beim Selberdenken. Aber Fefe, warum sehen wir eigentlich gerade keine Chemtrails?
Na ja, es gibt zwei Theorien. Die eine Theorie ist, dass die Bilderberger gewonnen haben. Die kämpfen sich seit vielen Jahren, müssen wir dazu sagen, bekämpfen sich seit vielen Jahren mit den Reptiloiden. Die Reptiloiden, die sind eher so biologisch-chemische Kampfwaffen und haben sozusagen Chemtrails gebraucht, um die Bevölkerung Gehirn zu waschen. Und die Reptiloiden sind eher so die Gegenthese. Also wie die sich genau geschlagen haben, ist ja von außen nicht erkennbar. Das sind ja Geheimgesellschaften. Also die eine These sagt sozusagen, dass das Virus hat jetzt die Wirksamkeit der Chemtrails beendet und ist sozusagen von den Reptiloiden in Umlauf gebracht worden.
Ich glaube, das ist eher anders. Ich glaube eher, die brauchten die Chemtrails nicht mehr, weil sie jetzt halt den Virus haben. Und mit dem Virus und bzw. mit der Impfung dann werden sie tatsächlich das Projekt Mind Control schlicht und ergreifend dadurch vollenden, dass wir dann alle den Mikroimpfungschip von Bill Gates bekommen.
Du meinst, es gibt gar keine Reptiloiden?
Doch, doch, Bill Gates ist ein Reptiloide.
Ach so.
Also ich glaube, Bill Gates hat einfach die Bilderwerke gekauft.
Ich glaube, der ist da mit anderer Technologie rangegangen. Der ist nicht so der Biologe, sondern der sucht so Hightech-Lösungen. Solutionismus nennt man das. Wenn Leute, da machen wir jetzt eine App für oder da machen wir ein Mikro-Controller hin. Bill Gates hat sich gesagt, was ihr da mit euren Chemtrails macht, das ist auch mittelalterlich. Wir machen hier mal moderne Methoden, 5G.
Also die Frage ist jetzt natürlich, ob tatsächlich der Virus selber das Mindcontrol-Agenz ist oder erst dann die Impfung?
Der Virus muss dich nur erstmal schwächen, damit du zugänglich bist, selbst für das noch nicht fertig ausgerollte 5G. Und wenn 5G dann fertig ausgerollt ist, brauchst du auch kein Virus mehr.
Naja, aber eigentlich waren auch die Chemtrails dafür da, uns zu schwächen, damit der Virus uns erreichen kann.
Nee, die Chemtrails, die haben wir schon seit Jahrzehnten. Die können nicht eine Vorbereitung für ein Virus gewesen sein.
Das weiß man nicht. Du weißt, so eine Verschwörung hat ja schon relativ lange, also ist ja schon ein bisschen länger unterwegs. Und ich meine, die New World Order braucht ja auf jeden Fall irgendeinen Mindcontrol-Agenz. Ich glaube ja, dass tatsächlich die Ritualiden und die Bilderberger haben sich zusammengetan. Also die haben sich ja seit vielen Jahrhunderten bekämpft. Aber ich glaube, die haben sich jetzt einfach zusammengetan und machen es jetzt halt einfach zusammen, weil sie eingesehen haben, dass es irgendwie Kooperationen viel besser funktioniert, als sich da irgendwie zu bekriegen. Und 5G, da konnten sich dann glaube ich drauf einigen. Aber vielleicht ist 5G ja auch von Q. Kann das sein, dass 5G von Q ist?
Also vielleicht brauchst du ja auch gar keine Mindcontrol, sondern es reicht, wenn du die Leute so ein bisschen Suppressionsfeier machst. Dass du die beschäftigt hältst und ihr Immunsystem ein bisschen schwächst. Und das hat dann die Chemtrails vorbereitet.
Und 5G ist jetzt einfach nur so der finale Todesstoß.
Weißt du, wenn du jemandem Elektronik oder was wie ein neues Organ einpflegst, dann musst du auch das Immunsystem erstmal runterfahren, damit es keine Abstoßung gibt.
Ja, ja.
Und das Virus, pass auf, das Virus, das soll jetzt das Immunsystem unterdrücken, damit die Implantate wirken. Die Mikrochips und die Impfung, die Impfung impft uns gar nicht, sondern setzt uns die Mikrochips ein, so ist das. Ist nur ein Vorwort.
Ja, so verstehe. Das heißt also, in der Impfung sind die Mikrochip-Quanten-Dots und sie haben die Chemtrails gebraucht, um das Immunsystem runterzufahren, damit die Quanten-Dots nicht abgestoßen werden. Und jetzt sind sie aber all soweit, dass wir die Chemtrails halt nicht mehr brauchen.
Weißt du, das Schöne an Quanten-Dots ist ja, dass das inzwischen anderweitig belegt ist, der Begriff. Das ist jetzt ein Begriff aus der Monitore. Ja, so LCD-Monitore mit besonders realistischen Fahnen benutzen Quanten-Dots. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt hier erzählst, die Quanten-Dots, dann beziehst du dich auf ein Experiment, was die WHO mal durchgeführt hat, wo es darum ging, wenn man Impfungen in Afrika macht. Und die haben aber alle keine Ausweise, weil die, es gibt so Meldewesen, gibt es da halt nicht. Wie machst du deine Datenbank und erkennst die Leute wieder? Und die Lösung war, dass du dir so ein Tattoo aus per Infrarot lesbaren Punkten machst, damit es nicht wie so ein Auschwitz-Ding aussieht. Ist das halt bloß im Auge nicht erkennbar. Aber du kannst es halt wieder erkennen als Impfarzt, der so ein Spezial-Lesegerät hat. Das war so die Idee. Und das hieß halt irgendwie, ich glaube, es hieß gar nicht Quantum Dots, aber so ähnlich. Aber das heißt, wenn du jetzt hier gerade von Quantum Dots erzählst, dann wirst du vielleicht noch andere von Media Mart kriegen, weil sie ihre Monitore nicht mehr abgesetzt kriegen.
Verstehe, es gibt also eine Namespace-Collision an der Stelle, ja. Na gut, okay, nachdem wir jetzt einmal festgestellt haben, was da draußen wirklich passiert, stellt sich dann immer noch die Frage, warum laufen da draußen eigentlich gerade so viele Spinner rum, die all diesen ganzen Quatschbrauch glauben, den wir gerade erzählt haben. Darüber wollen wir heute auch ein bisschen reden. Wir wollen vielleicht auch kurz über 5G reden und was irgendwie eigentlich damit nicht das Problem ist. Aber eben auch, was eigentlich da passiert, dass so viele Leute gerade so ein bisschen den Weg aus, sagen wir mal, so einer gewissen Konsensrealität, wir haben es ja mal den Major Consensus Narrative genannt, da so soweit raus sind, dass wenn man die öfter in der Straße trifft, auf einer von diesen Demos, man sich so denkt so, ja, also vielleicht wäre ja doch irgendwie mal so ein bisschen professionelle Hilfe eine gute Sache.
Schon zum eigenen Schutz. Also nicht nur um andere vor ihnen zu schützen, sondern auch.
Ja, ja, natürlich, klar, ja. Ich meine, das ist ja auch anstrengend, wenn man irgendwie denkt, dass die ganze Welt sich gegen einen verschworen hat, dass er dann doch auf die Dauer so ein bisschen ermüdend. Wir hatten ja im letzten Podcast darüber geredet, dass bei vielen Leuten das Abgleiten aus dem Major Consensus Narrative häufig ausgelöst wird in eine größere Entfernung. Der Major Consensus Narrative ist natürlich immer eine schwierige Problematik, die jetzt auch nicht immer problemfrei ist. Aber Leute, die dann plötzlich anfangen, AfD zu wählen oder plötzlich irgendwie Rassisten zu werden oder was von 5G und Bill Gates zu faseln, die haben häufig ja so ein Triggerevent hinter sich. Also irgendwas, was dazu führt, dass ihr normaler Alltag nicht mehr so richtig funktioniert oder dass da halt irgendwas dramatisch anders ist. Kann sein, dass sie einen Job verloren haben, dass Angehörige gestorben sind, dass irgendwie, also irgendwas passiert ist, was halt irgendwie, dass sie krank geworden sind, einen Unfall hatten. Also irgendwas, was halt dazu führt, dass sie halt irgendwie so ein bisschen primitiv gesagt aus der Bahn geworfen wurden, also aus den normalen Altersdingen. Und inzwischen können wir festhalten, dass also dieses Phänomen, dass das immer mehr Leuten passiert durch den Lockdown gerade, dass es schon eine wesentliche Rolle spielt. Was mir so oft fiel bei diesen Demos ist, dass da eine überproportional hohe Anzahl von Leuten so aus der Gastrobranche, also halt so Restaurantbesitzer und so dabei waren. Irgendwie einer von diesen Starköchen war ja auch unter anderem halt irgendwie so ein Veganer.
Genau, der ist ja Attila irgendwas.
Der war auch irgendwie da so ein Hauptprotagonist. Und für die ist natürlich halt gerade diese Lockdown-Nummer halt eine dramatische, dramatisches Triggereignis, was halt schon dazu führen kann, dass sie danach so ein bisschen komisch werden. Ich glaube, das spielt ja durchaus eine Rolle.
Einfach existenzielle Angstsituationen meinst du, ja?
Genau, und dann, wenn man sich dann so überlegt, es gab ja so ein paar ähnliche Geschichten, die dazu führten, dass Leute dramatisch den Eindruck hatten, dass sich ihre Welt verändert hat. So und also Tscharnobyl war zum Beispiel so ein Ding, da sprachen wir auch schon drüber. Und ich glaube, dass diese Art, dass sich das Universum um einen rum geändert hat, in einer Art und Weise, die dazu führt, dass der bisherige Alltag so nicht mehr funktioniert oder dass der bisherige Lebensunterhalt so nicht mehr funktioniert, dass der schon eine relativ große Rolle dabei spielt, dass Leute halt irgendwie denken, okay, irgendwie hat sich dieses Universum gegen mich verschworen, gegen mein Leben, gegen die Art und Weise, wie ich da halt irgendwie agiere, verschworen. Und ich kann mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, dass ich Pech gehabt habe.
Ich glaube, Verschwörung geht glaube ich zu weit. Denn Verschwörung impliziert ja, dass es da eine, irgendjemanden gibt, der das lenkt. Ich glaube, es ist noch, es gibt noch ein fundamentaleres Problem. Wenn man zum Beispiel sich anguckt, wie Depressionen behandelt werden, dann ist eine der wichtigsten Maßnahmen, die man einleiten kann, ist, dass man eine Struktur in seinen Tag bringt. Also dass man immer zur gleichen Zeit aufsteht, dass man versucht, immer zur gleichen Zeit irgendwie Mittagessen zu haben. Dass es überhaupt Leuten, vielen Leuten, in so die ins Schwimmen geraten, sage ich jetzt mal, weil das gerade schön passt, denen empfiehlt man, bring Struktur in deinen Tag. Und dieser Lockdown war für viele Leute sozusagen der Moment, in dem sie ins Schwimmen geraten sind. Und da ist die Versuchung groß, wenn man jetzt nicht mehr zur Arbeit gehen muss, dass man dann eben länger schläft. Das kann man ganz gut sehen, zum Beispiel gerade bei den Late-Night-Leuten in den USA. Die machen jetzt alle von zu Hause irgendwelche Broadcasts und es gibt nur einen von denen, der noch im Anzug broadcastet. Und der hat so als Witz am Rande gebracht, meinte, hör mal, wenn du nicht mehr einen Anzug trägst für deine Arbeit, dann ist dir dein Leben in Glitten. Das war so als als Joke am Rande gemeint, aber ich glaube, da ist was Fundamentaleres hinter und das stimmt. Ich glaube, wenn man plötzlich mehr Freiheitsgrade hat als vorher, kann das eine Befreiung sein, aber es kann auch plötzlich das Gefühl auslösen, dass man sozusagen am Abgrund steht und wenn ich jetzt was falsch mache, passiert irgendwas Schlimmes. Das ist keine rein positive Erfahrung, plötzlich mehr Freiheitsgrade zu haben, sondern es kann auch was Negatives sein. Es gibt auch Geschichten von Leuten, die aus dem Gefängnis entlassen wurden und dann mit der Realität nicht klarkamen und wieder zurück wollten. Also das ist, glaube ich, eine Sache, die viele Leute unterschätzen, wie wichtig das ist, eine Struktur im Leben zu haben. Und die Theorie muss nicht unbedingt sein, irgendjemand will mir Böses, sondern es reicht schon, wenn plötzlich irgendwie so ein, oh mein Gott, was mache ich jetzt? Das ist ganz anders als gestern.
Ja, also bloß wenn man sich die Leute anguckt, die da also sowohl im Netz als auch in der Realität auf diesen Demos halt da interessanten Dinge, die halt so…
Ja gut, die Demos, okay, das will ich nicht bestreiten. Wer auf die Demos geht, der ist nochmal zwei Schritte weiter. Aber ich glaube, dass alle so ein bisschen…
Ja, aber das sind jetzt nicht wenige Leute.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das interessiert mich aber schon halt so. Das ist völlig recht. Es gibt immer Leute, die irgendwie ein bisschen nicht klarkommen. Klar, haben wir irgendwie auch alle, dass wir irgendwie so unsere Probleme haben mit irgendwie, wie sich die Welt jetzt gerade neu strukturiert. So die einen mehr, die anderen weniger und damit halt irgendwie klarkommen müssen, wohl oder übel. Aber die Art und Weise, wie diese Leute klarkommen, die jetzt da auch in den Medien ja relativ weit berichtet werden, ist ja, dass sie glauben, dass irgendjemand sich gegen sie, die Demokratie, die Welt versporen hat. Und wir haben ja schon häufiger über Verschwörungstheorien geredet in diesem Podcast. Und ich glaube, wir müssen noch mal so ein bisschen grundsätzlicher anfangen. Weil natürlich ist es so, dass da draußen es Interessengruppen gibt, die ihre Interessen mit nicht öffentlichen Mitteln verfolgen, die jetzt auch nicht besonders demokratisch sein müssen. Und davon gibt es halt einige. Oder genauer gesagt, gibt es davon viele. Und die stehen halt auch in einer gewissen Art und Weise in Wettbewerb miteinander.
Lobbyisten, Religionen.
Genau. Unternehmen, ja, also ich meine, da muss man auch klar sagen, die größten Verschwörungen auf diesem Planeten sind halt einfach Unternehmen. Also die halt, oder vielleicht können wir die Religionen auch dazu zählen. So, und es gibt natürlich auch sowas wie irgendwie, sagen wir mal, die Bilderbarge. Also die gibt es ja tatsächlich. Es gibt ja halt irgendwie eine Gruppe von Menschen, die sich dadurch, dass sie sich absprechen und irgendwie dieselben Ideen in mehreren Ländern propagieren, versuchen, die Welt in eine Richtung zu treiben. Es gibt natürlich auch irgendwie diese Leute, die halt irgendwie immer so als der Davos-Zirkel bezeichnet werden, die sich dann halt in Davos treffen, da irgendwie bei diesem Event in der Schweiz und die halt eine ähnliche Welt Sicht haben, nämlich, dass irgendwie Globalisierung gut ist und dass halt irgendwie mehr Profit, irgendwie mehr Freiheit bedeutet.
Wir sollten kurz den Hintergrund geben, wer die Bilderberger sind. Weil, oder? Meinst du nicht, dass irgendwie der eine oder der andere... Ja, also die Bilderberger haben sich nach einem Hotel benannt, wo das ursprünglich stattgefunden hat, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Und das war einfach eine Gruppe von Eliten, also jetzt nicht im abwertenden Sinn, sondern halt so zoologisch gesehen. Politiker, irgendwie Leute aus wichtigen Konzernen, Staatssekretäre, die haben sich halt getroffen und wollten auch Journalisten und wollten sich halt mal austauschen. Und natürlich schwingt da immer so was mit wie, wie können wir jetzt hier mal in Ruhe durchregieren? Aber das war eigentlich nicht gedacht als Verschwörungsforum, sondern einfach als, da können wir mal in Ruhe reden, ohne dass darüber berichtet wird. Ich glaube, die Journalisten sind auch erst später dazugekommen. Oder war das nicht so? Das war so der Anfang vom Ende der Bilderberger, als dann Journalisten eingeladen waren und berichtet haben. Das ist eine typische Falle.
Nee, nee, die haben ja nicht berichtet, sondern die haben Journalisten eingeladen, damit sie dazugehören.
Ja, aber sie haben auch Journalisten eingeladen, die dann berichtet haben, wer da war. Also nicht, worüber die geredet haben.
Die haben sie nicht eingeladen, sondern das war von sich aus, dass sie davor hingekämmt haben mit Teleobjektiven, um irgendwie darüber zu berichten, wer da ist.
Paparazzi.
Das war so die Hochzeit der Bilderberger. Wichtigkeit war irgendwie, oder der wahrgenommenen Wichtigkeit war, dass sie Paparazzi vor der Tür hatten, die darüber berichtet haben, wer jetzt irgendwie alles da ist.
Also Bilderberg-Gruppe gibt es seit den 50er Jahren. Das ist jetzt nicht uralt wie, ich sag mal, die Luminaten. Naja, es gibt ja mehrere solche Treffen, wie Gipfeltreffen, wenn sich die NATO trifft, hat das ja eine ähnliche Funktion. Oder irgendwelche, die G8 oder was weiß ich, wie viele Gs das gerade sind, die sich da treffen, das geht ja im Grunde um dasselbe, dass die sich halt mal treffen, irgendwie gucken, sind wir alle noch auf derselben Seite. Vielleicht irgendwie an einem gemeinsamen Major-Consensus-Narrative arbeiten. Ja, aber das hat halt schnell in der Verschwörungstheorieszene dann so zu Sachen geführt, wie die da überlegen, gerade wie sie uns besser unterjochen können. Ja, weil wenn du eh so in dem Modus bist, die da oben ging, uns hier unten, wie bietet sich sowas natürlich an?
Also ich mein, garantiert gibt's da auch Leute, die überlegen, wie man halt irgendwie dieses lästige Volk irgendwie davon abhalten kann, irgendwie da irgendwie die Demokratiesimulation zu beeinträchtigen. Nur muss man sich halt, also ich mein, es gibt halt zum Beispiel auch echte Verschwörungen, zum Beispiel die Association of European Police Chiefs, was die da halt irgendwie so auf ihren Tagungen dann halt irgendwie so als ihren Major Consensus Narrative in ihrer Gruppe beschließen, das ist ja nur dann ein Consensus Narrative, findest du dann halt irgendwie ein halbes Jahr später in den Investoriums Vorlagen. Also, weil die sich dann halt darauf einigen, dass jetzt die Priorität ist, dass Krypto jetzt ganz böse ist und so. Nur muss man halt einfach die Perspektive behalten. Davon gibt es halt viele. Na, es gibt halt irgendwie auch jede Menge von diesen Gruppen, von denen habt ihr noch nie gehört, weil es halt irgendwelche Konzernlenkerveranstaltungen sind, oder irgendwie so, irgendwie was ist es nicht, so Espen zum Beispiel, da treffen sich halt auch irgendwie alle möglichen Eliteleute und so. Davon gibt es viele Dutzend so und es gibt auch etliche, so ein Asien zum Beispiel, von denen hast du hier noch nie gehört, die aber von der wirtschaftlichen Bedeutung her eine genauso große Rolle spielen, weil da halt dann irgendwie die Chefs von Alibaba und so dann halt irgendwie rumhängen.
Und das ist traditionell, sich nach dem Ort zu benennen, das können wir vielleicht mal sagen. Also nicht nur bei den Konzernen, auch in der Politik, da gibt es dann zum Beispiel die Shanghai-Konferenz, wo sich so eine Art Gegengewicht zur NATO irgendwie versucht hat zu formieren. Oder halt Hotels. Hotels sind sowieso beliebt, es gibt auch noch die Carlyle Group, die ist auch noch im Hotel benannt. Könnt ihr auch mal googeln, wenn ihr zu viel Zeit habt. Also das ist so die Tradition. Man trifft sich da halt, redet miteinander, macht wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie böse Dinge. Das wollen wir nicht in Abrede stellen. Aber dass sozusagen da der Kabal das nötig hat, irgendwie so eine Veranstaltung zu haben, um uns besser unterjochen zu können, ist halt offensichtlich Unsinn. Wenn die so viel Macht haben, dass sie die Weltbevölkerung unterjochen können, dann brauchen die sich nicht in einem Hotel zu treffen, sondern haben irgendwie Telefon.
Tatsächlich ist es halt so, dass es natürlich so, sagen wir mal, Gedanken gibt, die halt eine sehr große Rolle spielen, die dann halt auch einen sehr großen Einfluss haben. Also zum Beispiel so diese ganze neoliberale Gedankenwelt, also dieses, was dann in Deutschland irgendwie als Ich-AG ankam oder halt so die...
Was die Baden-Württemberg-Enschützung so erzählt.
Genau, also die Ausrufung der Sozialdemokratie, halt das Gedanken der sozialen Marktwirtschaft und seine Ersetzung durch halt so den relativ ungebremsten Kapitalismus und so. Das passiert natürlich in solchen Foren auch, nur es ist halt nicht ein Ding, sondern es ist halt eher so ein Konsens, der sich halt über eine gewisse Zeit formt, so wie es sich in der Wissenschaft einen Konsens formt darüber, dass jetzt halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Klimawandel dann doch vielleicht so ein Problem ist und dass man sich mal kümmern muss, der eine Weile gedauert, so ähnlich ist in solchen Zirkeln, gibt es dann halt auch unterschiedliche Ideen darüber, worum man sich jetzt halt mal kümmern muss und was jetzt halt so die Mittel sind, um halt irgendwie Profit und Macht irgendwie weiter zu sichern. Und davon gibt es halt viele und je nachdem, auf welche davon man sich konzentriert, kann man dann halt seine Welt sich shapeen und sagen, die Rothschilds oder die Bilderberger oder die Gnome von Zürich oder was auch immer einem da gerade so halt irgendwie einfällt. Und dazu gibt es irgendwie, muss man nochmal den Hinweis machen, es gibt dieses ganze Vorrang von Steve Jackson, das Illuminati New World Order Card Game.
Leider schon immer wieder ausverkauft.
Ja, auf eBay kriegt man es immer noch. Und der hatte sozusagen diese gesamte Welt von diesen gesamten Verschwörungstheorien halt ja einmal komplett irgendwie abgebildet. Man spielt halt eine von diesen Gruppen. Man spielt dann zum Beispiel die Bilderberger oder die Reptiloiden oder so als Machtgruppe, die versucht, irgendwie über Einfluss auf andere Gruppen die Welthorschaft zu gewinnen und dann den New World Order durchzusetzen. Und das ist halt eine grandiose Satire auf alles, was irgendwie diese ganzen Verschwörungstheorien, Exzesse sind. Vor ein paar Tagen habe ich gelernt, dass die jetzige Generation von Leuten, die ganz dollen Verschwörungstheorien glaubt, dieses Card Game gefunden und als, ja, Prophezeiung versteht. Das heißt, also es gibt ja...
Ich hatte den Eindruck, so ein bisschen als irgendwie, oh, das haben die versehentlich geleakt. Also gar nicht mal Prophezeiung, sondern so das...
Ja oder so, ja.
Die Idee, es kommt so tatsächlich von denen. Und das ist irgendwie für den internen Gebrauch. Und jetzt deswegen auch verkauft nach dem Motto... Ja, also das Problem ist ja, dass es nicht so einfach ist, so eine Theorie zu verifizieren, wenn man es denn versucht. Ja, und wenn man sagen wir mal, die Theorie hört, die Chemtrails wollen Gehirnwäsche, irgendwie Mindcontrol machen. Und man googelt dann nach wissenschaftlichen Papers zum Mindcontrol, dann findet man ja tatsächlich was. Das hat zwar mit den Chemtrails nichts zu tun, ja, aber das ist halt für den googelnden Line nicht unbedingt erkennbar. Und das Problem ist zum Beispiel in den USA wird die Wissenschaft nahezu komplett von dem Budget des Militärs bezahlt. Das heißt, wenn man irgendein Paper findet, was irgendjemand irgendwo gemacht hat, dann gibt es bestimmt einen Link zu irgendeinem Topf des Militärs. Ja, und sagen wir mal, irgendein Robotik-Fuzzi hat sich überlegt, er möchte jetzt mal, also was gab es denn da für schöne Beispiele? Es gab zum Beispiel eins, wo sie einen Insekt ferngesteuert haben über ein Implantat. Ja, haben sie irgendwie so was, einen Mikrocontroller drauf montiert auf das Insekt und dann haben sie das fernsteuern können. Ja, so das war eins der Versuche.
Und da denkt man, als Hobby-Experiment, wenn du ein bisschen schmerzbefreit bist, dann kannst du das tatsächlich irgendwie mit einer Kackalake selber rauchen. Gibt es so kleine Kids irgendwie?
Ja, ne, macht das mal nicht, liebe Hörer, behalte eure Ethik. Aber es gibt halt viele gruselige Forschungsgebiete, wo so moralbefreite oder, sagen wir mal, ethikflexible Personen dann Dinge forschen. Also das Krasseste, was ich mich jetzt gerade erinnern kann, ist, es gab mal einen Roboter, der sich mit Biomasse Energie verschaffen sollte. Ja, da gab es sofort die Assoziation, von wegen, der tötet dich und dann frisst er dich. So war das halt nicht gemeint, aber man weiß es halt nicht, wo das hingehen soll. Und natürlich gab es, weil alle Forschung irgendwie mittelbar über das Militär bezahlt wird, sofort ein Link zum Militär. Und wer weiß, vielleicht gibt es ja wirklich Leute im US-Militär, die gerne so Roboter hätten, die irgendwie den Feind dann fressen und sich damit Energie verschaffen.
Aber ich meine, für nach der Pandemie muss man ja irgendwie die Leichen weggraben, ne?
Es ist halt nicht so einfach, diese Verschwörungstheorien zu endkräften oder zu belegen, weil es einfach inzwischen so viel Kram online gibt, dass es fast egal ist, wonach du suchst. Du wirst immer irgendwas finden. Und die Einschätzung, habe ich, gibt es jetzt viel davon oder nicht? Oder gibt es nur dieses eine Crackpot-Paper, was ich jetzt hier gefunden habe? Ist das irgendwie eine reputable Quelle oder nicht? Das ist halt für einen Laien nicht so leicht zu beantworten, weil eben auch Leute, die, ich sag mal, aus dem etablierten Betrieb rausgeflogen sind, weil sie Spinner sind, die schreiben dann auf ihre Papers natürlich trotzdem ihre alte Uni drauf, weil das halt einen Ruf hat. Man muss also tatsächlich inhaltlich gucken, ob man sowas bewerten kann. Und das wollten wir mal ein bisschen versuchen.
Wir wollten aber erst mal noch gerade kurz über dieses Medienproblem dabei reden.
Ja, genau. Es gibt Facetten, es gibt verschiedene Facetten, die wir gerne beleuchten wollten.
Genau. Und wir haben ja da gerade das Phänomen, dass die Medien in Deutschland sind ja, sagen wir mal, in einer wirtschaftlich nicht besonders guten Situation, die halt irgendwie dadurch gekennzeichnet ist, dass sie jetzt halt irgendwie zu Zeiten des Lockdowns halt signifikant mehr Traffic haben, aber ihre Werbeeinnahmen dramatisch eingebrochen sind, weil niemand mehr Werbung schaltet. Was halt irgendwie jetzt auch nicht gerade dazu beiträgt, dass sie irgendwie mehr Geld für seriösen Journalismus ausgeben können. Kurzer Randeinschub, die sollten sich halt alle endlich mal zusammentun und sowas wie die DPA als eine Payment-Genossenschaft abbilden, damit sie halt irgendwie eine deutschlandweite Paywall Flatrate einführen können und man halt irgendwie genug Geld für Journalismus hat und trotzdem nicht mit Werbung belästigt wird und nicht irgendwie bei jeder Zeit eine eigene Paywall kaufen muss. Da ist aber vielleicht ein anderes Thema. Anyway, das Problem, was ich da gerade momentan sehe, ist halt, dass in vielen, also gerade auch in der Berichterstattung über jetzt diese Corona-Proteste neutral zu formulieren, dass da ein Großteil der Berichterstattung extrem undifferenziert ist und die sogar, also zum einen ist Quatsch, denen halt immer noch mehr Airtime zu geben, muss man einfach mal klar sagen. Das machen irgendwie Sputnik und Russia Today schon genug. Die halten ja da irgendwie mit Liebe gerne irgendwie ihre Kamera drauf, auch jeden, der irgendwie mit einer QAnon-Weste durchs Bild laufen möchte. Was halt irgendwie auch inzwischen schon wieder so Dimensionen angenommen hat, dass man einfach klar davon ausgehen muss, dass es halt irgendwie Absicht ist, um irgendwie unsere Wahrnehmung der Realität zu zersetzen.
Naja, aber von Anfang an, haben sie es nicht so angesagt, dass sie in die Gegenöffentlichkeit schaffen wollen?
Also sie haben jetzt die Zersetzung unsinn. Nee, haben sie angesagt, aber es ist halt, also zwischendurch gab es so eine kurze Phase, als es noch nicht so ganz klar war, was jetzt irgendwie das Heilige Mutterland Russland halt irgendwie tun wird, irgendwie mit diesem Corona und ob die überhaupt zugeben, dass es so was wie Corona gibt. Da waren sie so ein bisschen verwirrt, was sie jetzt irgendwie publizieren, aber mittlerweile haben sie sich darauf festgelegt, dass es zwar Corona gibt, aber irgendwie im Westen ist es ein anderes Corona als irgendwie in Russland oder so ähnlich. Und deswegen...
Da war doch Weißrussland. Die haben doch der Präsident halt angesagt, geht in die Sauna und trinkt Wodka und dann betrifft euch das nicht. Das fand ich...
Der Punkt ist, das mit der Sauna hat sogar einen wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund, weil tatsächlich irgendwie unter anderem eine der Studien, die relativ reputabel sind, die halt irgendwie die Aktivierung des erlernten Immunsystems angeht, relativ deutlich zeigt, dass irgendwie Hitze und Kältereize tatsächlich funktionieren. Also dieses Kalt duschen zum Abhärten hat tatsächlich einen wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund. Mittlerweile ist man wie so, dass sogar das funktioniert.
Auf der anderen Seite sind aber geschlossene Räume gerade schlecht für Corona und wenn irgendwie fünf fußende Leute in der Sauna sitzen, dann hast du danach fünf Infizierte, wenn einer eins hat.
Ich glaube, bei 100 Grad macht der Virus nicht allzu lange.
Da wurde ich mir jetzt nicht so überrascht. Ja, nee, nee, nee. Das ist ein Fehlschluss.
Und den Rest spürst du dann mit dem Wodka runter.
Bakterien sind anfällig gegen hohe und tiefe Temperaturen. Viren nicht so. Also auch, aber nicht so. Das ist ein Fehlschluss, dass du irgendwie was... Also viele Leute haben ja in den USA angefangen, ihre Post in die Mikrowelle zu schieben und haben dann Hausbrände ausgelöst, weil sie gedacht haben, wenn es nur heiß wird, ist der Virus tot. Also das funktioniert halt nicht. Also das glaubt man nicht, nur wenn irgendwie... Ja, wenn es brennt, ist es gut, aber dann, das ist so wie, kannst du dich auch... Es gab ja dieses geflügelte Wort schon wegen so und so, hilft gegen Corona oder nur, ja, eine Handfeuerwaffe hilft auch gegen Corona. So, weil wie...
Ja.
Anyway. Jedenfalls bei den Medien haben wir gerade so ein Problem, wo ich nochmal intensiv drauf hinweisen möchte, weil es mich gerade sehr anfrist. Und zwar sich da tatsächlich gerade dieses Phänomen, das häufiger mal die Vergangenheit umgeschrieben wird. Also wir hatten ja in dieser, also in den letzten zwei, drei Monaten so, seit irgendwie dieser Corona-Kram jetzt irgendwie akut wurde, gab es ja mehrere gravierende Änderungen der öffentlich publizierten Strategie. Und da ist auch überhaupt nichts Schlimmes dran. Das kann man doch einfach sagen, dass halt irgendwie sich Ansichten geändert haben, dass halt irgendwie man halt irgendwie auf der Basis von neuen Erkenntnissen halt irgendwie einfach seine Ansichten und seine Maßnahmen ändert. In einigen Fällen, also spezifisch beim Thema Masken, war es aber so, dass halt die Aussage vom Robert-Koch-Institut, was war, muss man einfach mal nochmal deutlich darauf hinweisen, das Robert-Koch-Institut ist eine Bundesbehörde, also es hat nicht irgendwie irgendwas mit Uni zu tun oder so, sondern es ist eine Bundesbehörde, die dem Gesundheitsministerium als... Das Gesundheitsministerium hat Weisungsbefugnis, das Robert-Koch-Institut muss man einfach auch klar verstehen. Und dementsprechend gab es dann da so ein paar Probleme in der Kommunikation, als es dann nämlich darum ging, ob jetzt Masken helfen oder nicht. Und ihr erinnert euch vielleicht dunkel, da gab es so eine Phase, wo die gesagt haben, ja, ach nee, mit den Masken wissen wir nicht, ob es so richtig hilft. Und dann gab es irgendwie so, ja, und auch diese Schutzmasken nicht, dass sie dann noch irgendwie andere Infektionen auslösen, weil die dann verkeimen und da kann doch sowieso keiner richtig mit umgehen und so. Und was aber tatsächlich so ist, das war halt nicht der Stand der Wissenschaft. Der Stand der Wissenschaft war, dass man zum Beispiel aus Japan weiß, dass so Grippeepidemien signifikant schwächer sind, die von Viren mit einer, sag mal, ähnlichen Infektionsverhalten verursacht werden. Weil die Leute da halt alle einfach einfache Masken tragen, einfache Stoffmasken. Natürlich helfen die vielleicht am Einzelfall nicht, weil der Virus halt relativ klein sein kann und die Tropfen relativ klein sein können. Aber selbst wenn sie halt nur die Ansteckungswahrscheinlichkeit reduzieren, was sie tatsächlich tun, helfen sie halt.
Das ist aber ein Missverständnis, was wir bei der Gelegenheit auch mal aufklären können. Wenn man aus Asien so Videoaufnahmen sieht, wo die Leute alle mit Masken rumrennen, die machen das nicht, um sich vor euch zu schützen, sondern die machen es, um die anderen vor sich zu schützen. Wenn eine Maske ziehen Chinesen an oder Japaner, wenn sie glauben, dass sie eine Erkältung haben. Das heißt, die Schutzwirkung geht in die Gegenrichtung, die man als Europäer annehmen würde. Das hat die Kommunikation so ein bisschen schwieriger gemacht. Und das Robert-Koch-Institut war in der ungünstigen Lage, dass unsere Regierung die Vorbereitung großflächig verkackt hatte. Weil in diesem Land keine Atemmasken mehr hergestellt wurden, sondern das ist alles wegen 0,3 Cent Profitmaximierung nach China outgesourct worden. Und was die eigentlich wollten, ist, dass nicht irgendwelche Horder sich die ganzen Masken kaufen und dann das Krankenhauspersonal keine mehr hat. Ja, das war auch relativ früh, haben sie das auch angesagt. Aber das führte eben dazu, dass als dann wieder genug Masken da waren, man ihnen vorhalten konnte, hör mal gestern habt ihr aber noch gesagt, irgendwie keine Masken. Und jetzt sagt ihr plötzlich doch, Masken habt ihr keine Ahnung oder was. Das ist dann so die Verschwörung.
Das ist der eine Aspekt. Der andere Aspekt ist aber, dass jetzt tatsächlich von Medien, wie zum Beispiel Zeit Online, da gibt es dann halt irgendwie sowas, ich zitiere gerade mal, ist ein Bericht über irgendwie einer von diesen Corona-Demos. Zu ihren Demo-Schlagern gehört die Erzählung, dass das Robert-Koch-Institut zu Beginn der Pandemie von Schutzmasken abriet, weil damals weniger verfügbar waren. So, hier wird es doch halt getan, als wäre das falsch. Aber das stimmt einfach. Das kann man nachweisbar, wenn man Tagesschau klickt, wenn man halt irgendwie die Verlautbarung vom Robert-Koch-Institut sich irgendwie anguckt. Genau das haben die damals getan. Die haben gesagt, ja, nee, mit den Masken lasst mal lieber, irgendwie so. Und dann geht es hier weiter, oder dass die Regierung angeblich nicht vorsorgt, obwohl die Gefeiner Virus-Pandemie schon 2012 an einem Papier des Bundestags skizziert war. Ja, auch das stimmt. So ist tatsächlich so, dass irgendwie Virologen schon seit vielen Jahren davor waren, dass wir irgendwie auf so eine Pandemie echt extrem unzureichend vorbereitet sind und halt einfach nicht genug Reserven da sind, nicht genug Masken und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt also Sachen, die demonstrierbar war, sind, werden jetzt dadurch, dass sie im Kontext von diesen Corona-Demos erzählt werden, retroaktiv zur Unwahrheit erklärt. Liebe Zeit, wenn ihr sowas schreibt, müsst ihr euch echt nicht wundern, wenn die Leute sagen, ihr seid Lügenpresse. Weil das funktioniert so nicht. Man muss einfach bei der Wahrheit bleiben als Presse. Man muss einfach sagen, was wahr ist und nicht Leuten unterstellen, nur weil sie anderweitig halt irgendwie 5G-Alohüte sind, dass sie, wenn sie Sachen sagen, die nicht, die wahr sind, dass diese Sachen dann plötzlich unwahr sind. Das funktioniert so nicht. Das gilt bei Association. Das geht halt einfach nicht für Sachen, die einfach Fakten sind.
Ich würde da auch gerne die Faktenfinder erwähnen, an der Stelle, der auch einfach seit Monaten schlecht negativ auffällt. Weil die einfach reine Ideologie da ausrollen und dann so tun, als hätten sie irgendwas widerlegt. Die Presse macht sich gerade mit ihrem Kampf gegen die Fake-News-Vorwürfe zum Stück Brot aus meiner Sicht. Das geht gar nicht, was da abläuft. Zur Ehrenrettung der Regierung sei aber auch noch mal gesagt, also eine Position, die ich sehr ungern vertrete, aber die Regierung hat eine lange Liste von Sachen, auf die sie nicht vorbereitet sind und die auch nicht geklärt werden. Wie zum Beispiel, dass unsere Schulen alle verkommen. Das ist jetzt eine Ländersache. Dass wie viele Brücken marode sind, dass die Autobahnen alle baufällig sind. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Regierung gesagt hat, okay den Rest reparieren wir, aber die Pandemievorbereitung verkacken wir. Nein, nein, das ist in einer langen Liste von Sachen, wo die Regierung verkackt ist, die Pandemievorbereitung ist eine davon. Das ist jetzt also nicht, dass die Gerne wollten, dass wir alle an der erstbesten Pandemie sterben, sondern das ist genau wie bei allen anderen Sachen, wo man mal was investieren könnte, haben sie halt gesagt, ach komm, das kann die nächste Legislaturperiode machen.
Genau, das sagen sie dann 40 Jahre lang.
Genau, bis halt was platzt und dann ist plötzlich Geld da. Also aus meiner Beobachtung ist das inzwischen so, dass wenn der ARD-Faktenchecker was sagt, dass das sogar eine negative Glaubwürdigkeit hat. Das heißt, Leute, die das lesen, sagen, okay, dann wird wohl die andere Seite gestimmt haben. Ja, das ist richtig doll schlimm verkackt, aus meiner Sicht, was die ARD da gemacht hat.
Vor allen Dingen, weil sie halt, muss man einfach sagen, die arbeiten ja halt nicht in einem Vakuum, sondern die arbeiten halt im Zweifel, auf der anderen Seite sitzen dann halt Leute bei Russia Today oder bei Sputnik oder Leute mit einem großen YouTube-Channel, die halt irgendwie nur darauf warten, dass sie da halt irgendeinen Quatsch machen, um halt einfach diese gesamte Institution zu diskreditieren, was sie jetzt erfolgreich mehrfach geschafft haben, was halt dazu führt, dass dieses gesamte Konzept, was ja ohnehin schon so ein bisschen fragwürdig war, von diesem Fact-Checking, also dass es sozusagen eine offizielle Instanz gibt, die jetzt die Wahrheit feststellt, dann halt eben leider erodiert ist. Und das Problem ist halt, das war einer der wenigen Ansätze überhaupt, um aus dieser Abschaffung von Wahrheit, von gemeinsamer Realität irgendwie rauszukommen. Also wenn du halt irgendwie versuchst, das halt neutral zu machen, und da halt nicht irgendwelche Ideologie zu transportieren, sondern halt wirklich einfach nur Fact-Checking machst, dann ist das natürlich sinnvoll. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel Snopes anguckt, das ist ja irgendwie so eine von den Hooks-Busting-Seiten im Netz, die halt relativ gut darin sind, das halt ganze Ideologie freizuhalten und halt irgendwie jetzt nicht irgendwie da versuchen, irgendeine Agenda zu transportieren, da sieht man, dass es ja eigentlich im Prinzip funktionieren kann. Aber leider muss man sagen, dass in Deutschland diese ganzen Ansätze, die das versucht haben, nicht alle, aber zumindest die von ARD waren halt, ist halt irgendwie, muss man leider sagen, ein relativ unschönes Beispiel und auch einige von den, sagen wir mal, überregionalen Zeitungen, das funktioniert halt so nicht. Und jetzt ist das Kind halt leider in den Brunnen gefallen. So jetzt ist die Glaubwürdigkeit halt zumindest bei einem Teil der Bevölkerung halt verspielt. Bei einem anderen Teil, denen ist es egal. Besonders glauben sie halt sowieso, die folgt erstmal, was in der Tagesschau gesagt wird. Aber das kann man halt eben doch einfach nicht so oft bringen. So das heißt, klar ist halt, wenn man halt irgendwie als Medium sowas macht, wenn man halt so Berichterstattung macht, die halt Faktenberichterstattung ist, dann muss man da halt auch versuchen, irgendwie klarköpfig zu bleiben und halt irgendwie möglichst wenig Ideologie zu versuchen zu transportieren, möglichst wenig Meinung. Es gibt ja, also man muss ja nicht immer nur meckern, es gibt ja tatsächlich irgendwie, bei Spiegel Online zum Beispiel, haben sie ja dieses, wenn irgendwie was sich um einen Attentat ist oder irgendwie Terror oder sowas, machen sie immer so ein, was wir wissen, was wir nicht wissen. Also wo sie versuchen halt irgendwie den Fock of War halt so ein bisschen zu sortieren und zu sagen so, okay, hierüber haben wir schon gesicherte Erkenntnisse, weil wir haben halt irgendwie mehrere Quellen, die halt sagen, so ist das halt gewesen und hier wissen wir halt noch nicht, können wir halt noch nicht sagen. Finde ich sehr gut, ist glaube ich so ein Ding, was man halt häufiger machen sollte, einfach das Spektrum der Unsicherheit auch klarer betonen.
Naja, also es gibt aber das Problem, dass inzwischen dank Identity Politics sehr häufig mit Guild-by-Association gearbeitet wird. Also zum Beispiel bei Snopes, das ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür, die sind sozusagen so nah, wie man kommen kann an irgendwie das reine Gute. Die haben halt die Heere Zielsetzung gehabt, die gibt es schon ewig lange. Die haben sich auch nie irgendwelche krassen Schnitzer geleistet. Und dann kam Facebook und hat gesagt, wollt ihr nicht bei uns irgendwie helfen? Und hat ihnen sozusagen einen Knopf gegeben, mit dem sie sagen können, unter einem Facebook-Posting, dass es aber widerlegt. Ja, so. Und das führt jetzt eben dazu, dass Leute sagen, nee, Snopes ist aber gekauft. Snopes ist nicht mehr vertrauenswürdig, weil es ja von Facebook gekauft. Was halt offensichtlich Blödsinn ist. Aber dieses, wenn man sich einmal auf dieses Spiel einlässt, dass man sagt, jemand ist böse, weil irgendwie der und der hat was gespendet, was ja auch das Hauptding gerade bei der Bill Gates-Verschwörung ist. Dieses Identity-Politics-Zeug, damit kannst du halt alles und nix belegen. Und sobald man sich darauf einlässt, hat man halt überhaupt kein Fundament mehr, auf dem man bauen kann. Also Snopes an der Stelle echt empfohlen. Das ist eine der wenigen wirklich vollständig empfehlenswerten Sites im Internet, wo es nix ist. Es gab auch mal das Gerücht übrigens, dass George Soros, die bezahlt haben sollen, das ist ja ein noch größeres rotes Duch, als das Facebook da investiert. Aber das war blöd.
Oder Bill Gates.
Ja, inzwischen Bill Gates. Bill Gates ist der neue George Soros, würde ich sagen. So von dem Hass, den er auf sich zieht. Aber gut, das soll es hier nicht um... Naja, der ist ja auch schon... Wie alt ist der? Über 90, oder? Der ist George. Also es gibt so ein paar Aufnahmen von denen, da sieht das schon echt gebrechlich aus. Gut, aber darum ging es. Also die Faktenchecker haben leider in die falsche Richtung gearbeitet.
Aber sie haben sich halt nicht darauf beschränkt, tatsächlich Fakten zu checken, sondern sie haben sich halt immer mehr, denn darauf kapriziert halt irgendwie die Kompatibilität mit dem Major Consensus Narrative zu bewerten und nicht irgendwie das, was wirklich passiert ist, herauszufinden. Und das ist halt irgendwie voranzustellen. Und das ist halt so einigermaßen nervig, weil sie haben damit halt diese Möglichkeit, Faktenchecking als Weg gegen Desinformation zu benutzen, relativ großflächig diskreditiert. Und das ist halt schon echt traurig.
Die ARD hat sich neulich so ein anderes Ding geleistet, was auch echt legendär nach hinten losgegangen ist. Da war so ein Artikel, der hat dann angefangen, irgendwelchen Leuten irgendwas widerlegen zu wollen und meinte, nein, nein, niemand. Also die, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was war jetzt genau die Dings. Irgendjemand hat gemeint, ja, demnächst irgendwie legen sie los und wollen das und das tun. Und dann haben sie irgendeinen Regierungsfuzzi gefunden, der meinte, nein, nein, das ging, glaube ich, um Lockerungen. So nach dem Motto, irgendjemand meinte, ja, demnächst die Lockerungen irgendwie werden zurückgefahren. Und dann meinte irgendwie Laschet oder so irgendein Politiker, nee, nee, niemand hat das vor. Und dann kommt irgendwie ARD Tagesschau und macht einen Artikel. Das ist alles irgendwie Fake News und Bullshit. Und eine Woche später kommt halt tatsächlich der Typ, von dem sie das gerüchtet hatten, und dreht sich halt um, ja, weil das eben passiert. Und dann stehst du mit so einem Artikel einfach da wie ein Vollidiot. Und das kannst du dir halt ein- oder zweimal leisten. Und dann ist dein Ruf durch. Ja, also wir möchte wenigstens noch...
Das Innenministerium, was halt Twittert irgendwie so, bitte helfen sie mit, das Information mit einzudämmen. Und vom 12. März oder 11. März oder so was. Niemand hat hier vor, irgendwelche starkeren Einschränkungen des örtlichen Lebens zu machen.
Niemand hat die Ansicht, die Bauern zu bauen.
So, ey, lasst so was einfach. Das ist halt irgendwie seitwählig mit den Menschen.
Kann man ja mal bringen, aber nicht als die Wahrheit darstellen, sondern es ist halt aktuell Stand der Dinge. Ich würde übrigens sogar noch weitergehen. Das ist nicht nur nicht schlimm, wenn sich der Stand ändert, sondern das ist gut. Das ist nämlich ein Zeichen, dass wir noch Wissenschaft machen und nicht Religion. Ja, wenn du auf eine Änderung der Faktenlage reagierst, indem du deine Position änderst, das ist ein gutes Zeichen. Das heißt, dass man dann auch was ändern kann, dass das nicht irgendwie die Ideologie ist.
Genau, aber das kann man auch einfach sagen. Dass man halt was sagt, so pass auf, wir haben einen neuen Sachstand und die Bewertung des Sachstands hat halt ergeben das. Aber man macht halt einfach nicht von vornherein so Aussagen, wie niemand arbeitet an einem Plan oder wir werden auf gar keinen Fall dieses oder jenes tun, dann sagt man das halt einfach nicht. Also deshalb, weil man es nicht ausschließen kann, schließt man es halt einfach nicht aus.
Ausschließen ist überhaupt ein gutes Stichwort, was ich auch nochmal ansagen wollte. Also wenn irgendjemand in der Presse schreibt, irgendwie so und so, kann nicht ausschließen, das schmeißt den ganzen Artikel direkt weg. Das ist eine Null-Aussage. Wer kann denn irgendwas mit Sicherheit ausschließen? Gerade in unsicheren Zeiten halten sich die Leute gern an sowas fest, aber die Aussage ist Null. Wenn die Presse schreibt, irgendwie so und so will nicht ausschließen, das einfach direkt in die Tonne.
Ja, wobei es ja immerhin eine Aussage ist im Gegensatz zu wir werden das niemals tun, wir waren noch niemals im Krieg mit Eurasien.
Das ist halt so eine Bullshit-Aussage, das sagt halt nix. Wenn du mich fragst, kannst du ausschließen, dass du irgendwie morgen jemand umbringst, dann würde ich dir jetzt natürlich sagen, irgendwie werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht tun, aber weißt du, wer weiß.
Ist unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, aber das ist eine andere Aussage. Kannst du ausschließen oder ist unwahrscheinlich, sind verschiedene Aussagen. Das heißt, die Frage, kannst du irgendwas ausschließen? Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. So und daraus dann eine Schlagzeile zu machen.
Da braucht man eigentlich drüber reden eigentlich.
Eben, das ist Unsinn. Der andere Klassiker an der Presse ist so und so, denkt darüber nach, ob, oder erwägt irgendwie so und so. Die Politik denkt drüber nach, ob wir den Lockdown, so Null-Aussage, ja natürlich denken die darüber nach, das ist ihre Aufgabe. Da könnte ich mich ja stundenlang darüber aufregen, diese Lenkenden irgendwie, weil der Effekt ist halt immer derselbe. Der Typ, der das liest, der liest halt nur irgendwie, der liest halt, was er lesen wollte. Das ist einer der Bias, die es so gibt. Das ist der, wenn man irgendwie eine vorgebildete Meinung hat und man fängt dann an, sich zu informieren und googelt rum und findet zwei Aussagen pro und zwei Aussagen dagegen, dann wird man die, die die eigene Haltung bestätigen, höher einschätzen. Und eine Sache, die nicht klar pro oder kon ist, das wird man versuchen, so zu deuten, dass sie pro ist. Ja, das ist der, es ist ein ein bekannter Beis, den die Menschheit eben hat und der wird eben befeuert durch diese Art von Berichterstattung. Das ist schädlich. Übrigens, wir haben jetzt das RKI gesagt, dass das Robert-Koch-Institut weisungsgebunden ist. Der Drosten ist nicht beim RKI, sondern bei der Charité. Ja, den Unterschied will ich gern nochmal öffentlich angesagt haben. Der hat auch von vornherein direkt diese Maskensache direkt so kommuniziert, hat gesagt, also wir haben nichts dagegen, dass die Leute Masken tragen, aber wir haben gerade zu wenig, um allen Menschen und dem Personal Masken zu geben. Insofern würde ich da im Zweifelsfall auch gar nicht beim RKI gucken, sondern beim Drosten. Der ist da unabhängiger.
Ja, definitiv. Da sind wir dann halt jetzt bei der genau dieser Frage, welchen Studien und welchen Wissenschaftlern kann man eigentlich trauen?
Ja, wenn man jetzt so eine Studie findet, woran erkenne ich denn, ob die vertrauenswürdig ist?
Und da gibt es auch Zeit, ob ich da irgendwas für mein Leben draus ableiten kann an Handeln.
Also das erste Problem, was man hat, ist, dass Studien normalerweise eine Kausalität nicht nachweisen, sondern nur eine Korrelation. Eine Korrelation heißt sozusagen, wenn die Sonne untergeht, wird es dunkel. Das kann heißen, es wird dunkel, weil die Sonne nicht mehr da ist, aber es muss es halt nicht heißen. Ja, eine Korrelation kann auch in die Gegenrichtung sein. Wenn es dunkel wird, geht die Sonne unter. Ja, und das heißt halt nicht...
Na ja, oder um es mal einfach zu sagen, also es gibt halt zum Beispiel, also wenn es dunkel wird, geht die Sonne unter. Das ist halt so, was wir normalerweise gewöhnt sind, aber vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur totale Sonnenfinsternis.
Genau.
Dann ist die Sonne nicht untergegangen.
Das erste Problem ist, dass viele Studien, gerade in den Anfangsstadien von einer Forschung zu einer neuen Krankheit, gehen erst mal nur so ein bisschen Evidenzsammeln dran. Ja, zum Beispiel gab es eine Studie, die hab ich auch verlinkt, da ging es dann darum, sie haben halt irgendwie mal so und so viele Tote angeguckt und haben halt mal geschaut, ob es da irgendwie eine Altersverteilung gibt und so. Und wenn man dann sehen kann, viele alte Leute sterben, dann kann man das aus verschiedenen Arten deuten. Da kann man entweder sagen, okay, ich bin jung, das betrifft mich nicht, das wäre eine Deutung. Das ist aber nicht, was in der Studie steht. Oder man kann sagen, okay, die werden eh bald gestorben. Das ist auch nicht, was in der Studie steht. Außerdem ist das heutzutage gar nicht mehr so klar, wie lange jemand leben kann, selbst wenn er vorher Krankheiten hatte. Also das ist die erste Hürde, die man nehmen muss, dass die Studie wahrscheinlich von Korrelationen redet und nicht von Kausalzusammenhängen. Da muss man aber aufpassen, dass man es nicht als Kausalzusammenhang liest. Das Problem ist auch, dass viele Sachen heutzutage nicht einfach aus A-Volk B ist, sondern so Multifaktor, Multikausal. Also zum Beispiel von Rauchen steigt das Krebsrisiko. Das heißt nicht, dass du, wenn du nicht raust, kein Krebs kriegst. Sondern es ist halt nur ein Faktor. Und entsprechend ist das eben auch hier bei der Pandemie. Da gibt es eben verschiedene Faktoren, die wir jetzt der Reihe nach raus isolieren müssen. Und gucken, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich die Auswirkung. Das hat sich auch schon verschoben seit von Anfang an. Erst hieß es, okay, das ist eine Grippe. Dann hieß es, es ist keine Grippe, sind Corona-Viren, aber es löst eine Lungenentzündung aus. So, und dann hat man gesagt, okay, aber Lungenentzündung ist nur das häufigste Symptom. Eigentlich greift der Zellwände an in den Blutgefäßen. Da gibt es so eine Isolationsschicht, die wird davon angegriffen. Das heißt, wenn die Leute nicht an der Lungenentzündung sterben würden, dann sterben sie an anderen Folgen davon. Und die können sowas sein wie ein Herzinfarkt oder ein Nierenversagen oder ein Schlaganfall. Und sowas kann man manchmal prognostizieren anhand von Korrelationen, aber eben nicht immer. Also eine Sache zum Beispiel war, dass es Messungen gab von den Leuten, die in Corona-Intensivstationen künstlich beatmet wurden, da waren die Lebenserwartungen halt sehr gering. Da sind irgendwie 90 Prozent von gestorben. Und da könnte man jetzt sagen, okay, beatmen bringt nichts. Ja, das wäre eine Deutung, das steht da aber nicht. Oder man könnte sagen, okay, das liegt vielleicht daran, dass das Virus auch andere Sachen schädigt und die Lungenentzündung hier nun ein Symptom war. Oder vielleicht eins der Symptome. Das heißt ja nicht, dass die nicht die Lunge angreift, aber es ist halt nur eins der Probleme. Und bis wir das alles ausklamüsert haben, muss man halt aufpassen, nicht vorschnell irgendwelche Schlüsse zu ziehen. Und der Hauptstreit im Moment ist ja auch gar nicht, um die Fakten ist jedenfalls mein Eindruck, sondern ist so, hör mal, so schlimm war es doch nicht. Ja, das ist eher die Deutung davon. Wenn wir jetzt mit einer neuen Pandemie konfrontiert sind und wir kennen einfach die Rahmenbedingungen noch nicht, sagen wir dann, okay, wir machen jetzt hier mal aus Vorsorge einen Lockdown, damit uns weniger Leute sterben als sonst. Oder nicht. Oder das Modell Schweden, wir riskieren es halt. Oder so ein Mittelding. Also Schweden ist ja eigentlich schon ein Mittelding. Die haben es ja nicht einfach irgendwie riskiert, sondern die haben gesagt, okay, wir isolieren die Leute, die nach Stand der Forschung besonders gefährdet sind. Und der Rest kann weitermachen. Also das ist aber, das ist sozusagen die Politikdebatte, das ist nicht die Faktendebatte. Und was ganz scheiße ist, ist wenn du sagst, nachdem der Lockdown funktioniert hat, was er ja hat, ja die Ansteckungsquote ist unter eins im Moment, dass du dann sagst, ja das hätten wir nicht machen müssen, offensichtlich. Weil es hat sich ja keiner angesteckt. Das ist absolut absurd. Das ist wie wenn man sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt irgendwie Sex mit Kondom gehabt und keinen Nachwuchs gezeugt, jetzt machen wir halt ohne Kondom Sex, da wird dann auch kein Nachwuchs. Das ist doch Blödsinn, offensichtlich. Also das ist eben aber auch ein Problem des Umfeldes, was einfach da ist. Wir können jetzt nicht sagen, wie es gelaufen wäre, wenn wir keinen Lockdown gehabt hätten. Das wissen wir halt nicht. Also nur weil es ein anderes Land gibt, vielleicht, was es keinen Lockdown gemacht hat und wo wir irgendwas beobachten können, ist es nicht, dass bei uns auch so gewesen ist. Also diese Vergleichbarkeit ist nicht unbedingt klar.
Zumal halt das Problem ist, dass wir bei den verschiedenen Lockdowns in unterschiedlichen Ländern, die ja zum einen stark unterschiedliche Quoten von Letalität und auch von Ansteckungsrate haben, selbst innerhalb des selben Landes mit dem selben Gesundheitssystem. Also ein schönes Beispiel dafür ist zum Beispiel die Schweiz, wo sich herausgestellt hat, dass sowohl die Ansteckung als auch die Tödlichkeit in den unterschiedlich sprachigen Kantonen innerhalb der Schweiz relativ stark unterschiedlich ist, wo es halt verschiedene Theorien darüber gibt, ob es da genetische Faktoren gibt, ob es da soziale Faktoren gibt. Das ist halt nach wie vor so ein bisschen unklar. Also die Theorie ist halt zum Beispiel, dass in den italienischsprachigen Kantonen mit relativ hohen Todes- und Ansteckungsraten, dass es halt einfach damit zusammenhängt, dass die Familienverbände, Alt, Jung, Enger zusammenleben und dass der durchschnittliche Abstand in der Kommunikation geringer ist und die Sprache halt mehr lauter hat, die halt irgendwie mehr Tröpfchenbildung verursachen. So ist halt eine Theorie. Kann natürlich auch sein, dass es einfach der Rotwein ist oder was auch immer, wissen wir nicht. Na, das ist halt so und wir haben jetzt aber trotzdem halt irgendwie das Phänomen, dass wir dadurch, dass in den Lockdowns an so vielen Parametern gleichzeitig gedreht wurde, ist halt gerade so ein bisschen schwer es einzuschätzen, was jetzt wirklich die zum Beispiel die Risikozonen, die Risikoverhaltensweisen sind. Klar scheint, relativ klar scheint zu sein, dass das Hauptproblem indoors ist, das heißt also Innenräume sind das eigentliche Problem. Alles was draußen passiert, also viele Leute haben sich darüber aufgeregt, dass die Leute in den Parks jetzt irgendwie jetzt nun nicht irgendwie immer den Sicherheitsabstand eingehalten haben. Interessanterweise scheint das jetzt irgendwie nicht so eine massive Auswirkung zu haben, zumindest was wir bisher sehen. So immer vorsichtig sein, aber halt so kritischer sind halt irgendwie Innenräume.
Busse waren halt besonders schlimm und sind beforcht worden.
Ist ja ein Innenraum.
Naja, aber Innenraum ist halt auch erst dann schlimm, wenn es außerhalb deiner Familie ist, also mit irgendwelchen anderen Leuten zusammen.
Genau, also wenn halt du Innenraum außerhalb deiner eigenen Infektionsgemeinschaft. Genau. Und die Frage ist dann eben aber, wie passen wir jetzt halt irgendwie diese Lockdown-Regeln an für die nächste Welle? Also was sind denn die Sachen, die dann tatsächlich weiterhin untersagt sind? So momentan ist zumindest, was ich so in Berlin sehe, machen viele Gastronomen nur ihre Außenbereiche auf, also sagen, draußen sitzen ist okay. ZB gehen die Leute auch freiwillig lieber nicht rein, weil sie intuitiv das richtige Gefühl haben, dass draußen besser ist als drin. Das heißt, vieles von dem, was im initialen Lockdown passiert ist, war möglicherweise tatsächlich nicht so wirksam. Also ich würde jetzt mal nicht sagen unnötig, aber sagen wir mal nicht so wirksam, dass es möglicherweise den Schaden, der dadurch anderweitig entstanden ist, gerechtfertigt hat. Und ich glaube, dass dieses Problem, wie man jetzt die Maßnahmen in Detail konfiguriert und was davon welche Auswirkungen hat, das sauber zu managen und zu kommunizieren, ist jetzt so eines der großen Problemfelder. Und die Wissenschaft ist jetzt ja gerade in so einer Situation, was dies halt auch nicht einfacher macht, dass ganz viele von den Studien sind halt nicht peer-reviewed. Das heißt also ganz viele Studien, gerade zu Corona, werden halt publiziert, sobald sie fertig getippt sind. Also dann lässt man vielleicht nochmal einen Kollegen drüber lesen, aber dann gehen die halt raus, weil der Druck so groß ist, dass man halt irgendwie Lösungen finden will. Und alles, was irgendwie so aussieht, als könnte es uns irgendwie uns weiterbringen, weil es halt in der einen oder die andere Richtung halt für oder gegen eine Maßnahme spricht oder eine Behandlungsmethode ist oder was auch immer, wird halt publiziert, weil sie halt im Zweifel Leben retten kann und man relativ schnell validieren muss, ob das halt tatsächlich irgendwie der, sozusagen dem im konkreten Falle hilft. Also zum Beispiel ein Beispiel dafür war, die Sache mit der Bauchlage bei der Beatmung. Also dass halt irgendwie die Chinesen relativ bald festgestellt haben, dass Leute, die beatmet werden müssen, also auch nicht nur intubiert beatmet, sondern auch mit Masken beatmet, dass bei denen die Überlebensrate signifikant steigt, wenn die halt auf dem Bauch liegen oder so halb auf dem Bauch, halb auf der Seite liegen, was einfach anatomische Gründe hat. Und das haben die halt relativ schnell rausgehauen, ohne große Peer Review. Und das hat Leben gerettet, dass sie das getan haben, weil andere Ärzte dann daraus Folgerungen ziehen konnten. Selbes Problem mit den Studien, die halt zur Blutgerinnung kamen, dass also dieses Coronavirus bei einigen wenigen Wünschen dazu führt, dass es halt irgendwie massive Gerinnungen gibt, die halt irgendwie dann zu Schlaganfällen, Lungenembolien und so weiter und so fortführen. Und daraufhin sich dann halt auch relativ schnell das Behandlungsschema umgestellt hat und gesagt hat, okay, alle Leute, die mit Corona irgendwie ins Krankenhaus kommen, kriegen halt erstmal Blutverdünner, um dem vorzubeugen. Auf der anderen Seite werden aber auch Studien publiziert, wo man sagen muss, naja, das ist jetzt aber halt relativ, also wie zum Beispiel halt diese Chlorokin-Geschichte, wo halt zwar schon klar war, das funktioniert offenbar irgendwie. Also wenn du es zur richtigen Zeit irgendwie einsetzt, in der richtigen Dosierung und dieses Zeitfenster ist halt relativ klein, das Versuchungsfenster ist auch sehr klein, dann hat es eine positive Auswirkung. Aber die Nebenwirkungen bei einem Großteil der Leute sind extrem groß. Und wenn du halt irgendwie außerhalb des Fensters bist, in dem halt irgendwie tatsächlich die Wirksamkeit hilfreich ist, schadet es halt eher. Das war halt aus dieser kleinen Studie, die da halt am Anfang publiziert wurde, schlicht und ergreifend noch nicht zu entnehmen. Sondern hat sich dann halt erst dadurch rausgestellt, dass halt irgendwie weltweit exponentiert wurde. Man muss halt einfach verstehen, die Ärzte sind halt gerade halt eher in so einer Schlachtfeldsituation. Das heißt, die versuchen halt irgendwie so schnell, wie es irgendwie geht, halt da hinzukommen, dass sie halt Erkenntnisse publizieren. Und da muss man dann halt als Laie genau hingucken, was man halt mit diesen Studien tut und wie man die halt irgendwie bewertet und ob man da halt irgendwelche Folgerungen für sich draus zieht.
Oder man macht sich den Stress gar nicht erst. Also es ist ja auch im Grunde so eine nervöse Schutzreaktion, dass man jetzt zu Hause im Lockdown die Zeit damit überdrückt, irgendwelche Studien zu googeln, hat man ja vorher auch nicht gemacht. Aber es ist so ein Reflex aus meiner Sicht, den man auch beobachten kann, wenn Leute irgendwelche Krankheiten diagnostiziert werden. Sagen wir mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, es muss ja jetzt nichts Schlimmes sein, sag ich mal, irgendein Ausschlag oder so. Dann fängt man halt an zu googeln und hat auch erst mal keine, kann es nicht beurteilen, ob die Ergebnisse jetzt taugen oder nicht. Das ist ein generelles Problem. Und ich möchte aber noch eine Lanze brechen für die Leute, die jetzt die Studien machen. Selbst, wenn sich das als falsch herausstellt, kann es trotzdem Leben retten. Denn ich sage mal, die Studie kommt jetzt irgendwie, es gibt Leute, die einen Schlaganfall kriegen. Selbst, wenn du, wenn das deine Behandlung nicht ändert, ist das dann eine Sache, auf die du gucken kannst als Arzt. Hat ja hier Anzeichen vom Schlaganfall. Und gerade bei Schlaganfall ist es sehr wichtig, dass man es schnell erkennt, damit man noch was machen kann. Also das ist schon richtig und wichtig, dass die Leute jetzt schnell ihre Studien raushauen. Selbst, wenn es sich im Nachhinein als nicht so irgendwie, dass es nur bei wenigen Leuten stimmt oder dass es nicht verallgemeinerbar ist oder so. Selbst dann ist es wichtig, dass das alles publiziert wird. Und was der die Anomalie ist jetzt nicht die Studien, sondern dass wir plötzlich alle im Internet klicken und irgendwelche Studien finden. Die gibt es immer, die Studien zu irgendwelchen Gebieten, die gerade neu sind. Und gerade Gebiete wie Corona, bei denen es plötzlich Funding gibt. Da gibt es natürlich besonders viele neue Studien. Aber das ist ein Problem, was jetzt nicht coronaspezifisch ist, dass man bei Studien als Laie im Grunde schlechte Karten hat bei der Beurteilung, was das jetzt heißt.
Also es gibt so ein paar Sachen, also für mich ist es halt immer so, die Frage, wenn ich halt irgendwas lese, ok, dieses oder jenes, scheint eher positiv zu sein, so an Verhalten oder an relativ harmlosen Sachen, die man halt irgendwie in seinem Hand haben kann. Also so was wie, viele Studien sagen halt, dass der Vitamin-D-Status halt eine relativ große Rolle dabei spielt, dass halt irgendwie, wie anfällig man ist, infiziert zu werden. Deckt sich halt mit vorheriger Studienlage, weil irgendwie auch andere, insbesondere Erkältungsviren, die halt auch hoffentlich eine ähnliche Struktur haben wie Corona, dass die halt beim höheren Vitamin-D-Pegel halt irgendwie einen schweren Stand haben und halt irgendwie man sich nicht so häufig infiziert. So, jetzt kann ich halt überlegen, ok, was tue ich mit dieser Information? Hinreichend gute Vitamin-D-Pegel zu haben, ist sowieso eine gute Sache, auch noch für andere Sachen wie irgendwie Laune und Konzentration. Also kümmere ich mich mal darum. Der einfachste Weg, sich darum zu kümmern, ist halt einfach mehr raus in die Sonne zu gehen. Und einfach dafür zu sorgen, dass man genug Sonne bekommt, damit man halt sein Vitamin-D irgendwie ok hat. Man kann natürlich auch anfangen, Vitamin-D-Tabletten zu nehmen. Da muss man halt vorher mal lesen, wie viel man davon maximal nehmen sollte und was man noch dazu mischen sollte, damit man halt irgendwie keinen Scheiß baut. Aber ich sag mal, relativ harmlos.
Weil selbst da gibt es Probleme. Ich hab da eine längere E-Mail-Diskussion mit einem Nierenarzt gehabt. Und der meinte, wie viel Vitamin-D man denn haben sollte, das ist auch schon umstritten, woran man das jetzt erkennen soll. Und die aktuellen Ratschläge, die handeln wohl von Knochenschäden. Dass man sagt, wenn keine Knochenschäden auftreten, ist gut. Aber es gibt halt noch andere Kriterien, die man ansetzen könnte. Und am besten ist es, man geht zum Arzt und lässt einen Blutspiegel machen. Denn der kann dann sehen, ist der Vitamin-D-Spiegel zu klein? Und der kann einem sagen, wie viel man nehmen soll. Also, einfach Tabletten einzuwerfen ist zwar nicht sonderlich gefährlich, aber es ist auch nicht komplett ungefährlich. Denn es gibt auch ein Krankheitsbild für zu viel Vitamin-D nehmen. Das heißt, wenn ihr...
Super selten. Ja, also diese Studie mit dem zu viel Vitamin-D war von israelischen Rettungsschwimmern, die so den ganzen Tag in der Sonne waren, denen sie 10.000, die eh eingeholfen haben, die hatten dann halt irgendwie zu viel Vitamin-D-Anzeichen. Worauf ich hinaus will...
Worauf ich hinaus will, Vitamin-D-Mangel gibt's bei Leuten, die den ganzen Tag drin sind oder die dunkle Haut haben und daher... Also die Hauptquelle für Vitamin-D im Menschen ist Sonnenlicht. UV-Strahlen löst in der Haut was aus und da kommt Vitamin-D raus. Und wenn du... Wenn man eine dunkle Haut hat, kommt halt weniger Sonnenlicht durch. Das heißt, die müssen für den gleichen Pegel länger in der Sonne sein. Das heißt, wir sind hier gerade als hellhäutige Deutsche. Im Frühling, bei ständigem Sonnenlicht, sind wir sozusagen in der optimalen Situation. Ein zu viel Vitamin-D durch im Sonnenlicht sein hat es noch keinen einzigen Fall gegeben. Insofern ist der Rat von mir jetzt nicht irgendwie Pillen zu machen, sondern lieber jeden Tag mal 10, 20, 30 Minuten draußen rumzulaufen, dann ist gut. Und wer das eh macht, der muss sich keine Sorgen machen.
Aber Vitamin-D ist ja auch nur ein Platzhalter hier gerade. Genau, also Vitamin-D war jetzt sozusagen nur der Platzhalter für... Wenn irgendwelche Studien sagen, das scheint halt irgendwie eine positive Auswirkung zu haben, es ist relativ Low-Risk im Vergleich zu allen anderen Sachen, dann kann man das halt einfach machen. Wenn halt irgendwie die Studie sagt, hier Chlorokin könnte helfen, dann anzufangen, sich irgendwie Chlorokin aus dem Aquariumsbedarf rein zu pfeifen, ist dann halt schon eher so auf der Nicht-Nicht-Machen-Liste. Das heißt also, letzten Endes muss man halt einfach mal gucken, was sind tatsächlich die möglichen Folgerisiken einer Fallinsänderung. Und wenn die halt jetzt einfach, sagen wir, wenn jetzt sich rausstellt, okay, genug Sport machen, führt halt auch dazu, dass man irgendwie weniger wahrscheinlich Corona kriegt, dann ist das halt eher so ein No-Brain-Erner. Also dann macht man halt irgendwie ein bisschen mehr Sport, um halt irgendwie kein Corona zu kriegen.
Was man ja auch eh machen sollte, selbst wenn es kein Corona gibt, sollte man über mehr Sport machen.
Genau, und dann gibt es halt so diese grenzwertigen Sachen, so dieses halt irgendwie, diese statistische Studie aus Frankreich, die halt sagte, so Nicotine könnte halt möglicherweise helfen. So, die halt auch jetzt nicht unumstritten ist, weil sie halt möglicherweise einen Selection-Bias hat. Das heißt also, die beruhte halt auf der Beobachtung, dass relativ zur Bevölkerung weniger Raucher unter den in den Krankenhäusern auftauchenden Covid-19-Fällen sind. Vielleicht irgendwie normalerweise haben sie, glaube ich, 25 Prozent irgendwie Raucher in der Bevölkerung und irgendwie tauchten unter den Leuten, die im Krankenhaus auftauchten, waren nur 5 Prozent als Raucher erfasst. Und da gibt es jetzt wiederum mehrere Möglichkeiten. Entweder es funktioniert und es stimmt, wäre es halt irgendwie jetzt Nikotin jetzt so eher so in der Grenze von, irgendwie könnte man sich überlegen, ob man Nikotin konsumiert.
Nee, sollte man nicht mal zum Arzt gehen, wenn man Fragen hat zum Arzt gehen, bevor man irgendwas macht, was gefährlich sein könnte.
Lass mich kurz den Grenzfall erläutern. Oder man überlegt sich so, lass mich doch mal kurz zu Ende reden. Oder man sagt sich, das ist ein relativ stark abhängig machendes Suchtgift, was Kreislaufauswirkungen hat. Und wenn man es in Form von verbrennendem Tabak konsumiert, hat auch eine relativ hohe Wahrheitlichkeit, einen mit Krebs zu versorgen. Das ist dann in der Risikoabwägung eben schon nicht mehr so geil. Und da ist dann so jetzt die, um mal so ein bisschen so die Grenzlinie zwischen Vitamin D und Chlorokin in der Mitte zu ziehen, würde ich so sagen, Nikotin ist an dem Punkt, wenn du eh Nikotin vapest, bist du eh nikotinabhängig, dann macht das halt, das ist jetzt halt irgendwie, hat jetzt irgendwie weder positiv noch negativ, im Sinne von deswegen anzufangen, Nikotin zu konsumieren, weil du glaubst, dass Nikotin gegen Covid-19 hilft, wäre der falsche Ansatz. Also das halt so, um mal halt irgendwie die Schadensabwägung halt irgendwie nochmal ein bisschen klarer zu erklären. Und ich bin ja tatsächlich ein großer Verfechter davon, selber Studien zu lesen. Und zwar aus folgendem Grund. Es dauert in der Regel eine ganze Weile, bis neue Erkenntnisse in der Medizin tatsächlich ankommen, in dem, was irgendwie in der Breite im medizinischen Handeln umgesetzt wird. Also halt klassisches Beispiel sind zum Beispiel Magengeschwüre. So Magengeschwüre waren über Jahrhunderte bis, muss man einfach sagen, Ende der 90er so ein richtig großes Thema. Also wo halt Leute einfach auch elendiglichst dran verreckt sind unter barbarischen Schmerzen und wusste, also eigentlich fast noch in den 2000er so, und man wusste trotzdem schon eine Weile vorher aus einer guten Studie, dass Magengeschwüre in den allermeisten Fällen von Bakterien namens Heliobacter pylori verursacht werden, was mit einer sehr einfachen Antibiotika-Behandlung weggeht. Also man hat halt so einen Test, da pustet man dann so ein Röhrchen und irgendwie stellt dann halt irgendwie die Graszusammensetzung im Atem fest. Daraus kann halt irgendwie dediziert werden, ob man Infektionen mit diesen Bakterien hat, kriegt man halt diese Antibiotika verschrieben und dann war es das halt irgendwie mit den Magengeschwüren und nicht jahrzehntelanges Sichtum und aufbrechende Magengeschwüre und irgendwie Tod unter grausamen Schmerzen. So und es hat mehr als ein Jahrzehnt gedauert, bis diese Erkenntnis sich in den medizinischen Leitlinien wiedergefunden hat. Und da gibt es natürlich jede Menge Verschwörungstheorien drum, warum es so war. Einer davon ist, dass halt irgendwie die Säurehemmer, die halt irgendwie von den ganzen Magengeschwür-Opfern halt lebenslang genommen werden mussten, halt ein riesiges Einnahmegebiet für die pharmazeutischen Konzerne waren. Das ist doch bestimmt Bill Gates dahinter. Bestimmt Bill Gates dahinter. Also ich will nur erklären, warum es tatsächlich so ist, dass es gibt halt Fälle, wo man einfach sagen muss, dass es einfach zu lange dauert, dass medizinische Innovationen in der Praxis ankommen. Gerade sieht es aber nicht so aus. Also gerade ist es offensichtlich so, dass die Geschwindigkeit mit der, eben unter anderem auf der Basis dieser Publikation von nicht-perivierten Studien, die dann halt irgendwie an das Mal nachvollzogen und dann relativ schnell aussortiert oder irgendwie weiterverfolgt werden, ist die Innovationsgeschwindigkeit in der Medizin dramatisch angestiegen. Muss man einfach mal klar sagen. Was leider nicht in derselben Geschwindigkeit angestiegen ist, muss man sagen, ist in Deutschland dieses Reporting. Also das ist so ein Ding, was mich gerade so ein bisschen bewegt, ist irgendwie, wie sehr Deutschland nicht in der Lage ist, ein einheitliches Reporting mit irgendwie hinreichend großer Datendichte bereitzustellen aus den Gesundheitsämtern. Wir diskutieren über irgendwelche Apps und so einen Quatsch und relativ großen Datenschutzniehwirkungen, wenn man sie falsch machen würde. Zum Glück passiert jetzt wohl das nicht. Wir kriegen es aber nicht hin, aus den Gesundheitsämtern eine einheitliche Statistik zusammenzukriegen, die halt irgendwie im Stundentakt irgendwie reportet wird, sodass man halt einfach mal sehen kann, wo sich neue Cluster bilden und vor allen Dingen unter welchen Umständen diese Cluster zustande kommen. Weil auch eines der Probleme, was wir gerade haben, ist, dass es innerhalb des Reportings von neuen Fällen, die ja dann vom Gesundheitsamt nachverfolgt werden, da gibt es ja dann Contact-Tracing-Teams, die dann halt anrufen und sagen so, ja, du hast eine Idee, wo du das da eingefangen hast, mit wem hast du zusammengehangen, irgendwie, wen hast du da möglicherweise angesteckt, wo warst du dann an irgendwelchen öffentlichen Orten und so weiter und so fort. Also, die gehen dann mit einem relativ ausführliches Leben vor dem Zeitpunkt und nach dem Zeitpunkt der Infektion durch. Und da entstehen natürlich eine Menge Daten. Und die könnte man auch sauber anonymisiert und klassifiziert zusammenfassen, um halt irgendwie die Lockdown-Maßnahmen auch einfach mal anzupassen, zu sagen so, okay, hier haben wir eine hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit von Infektionen basierend auf Daten, die aus dem Reporting kommen. Und das ist immer sowas, wo ich dann wenig Verständnis für habe, wenn die Daten eigentlich da sind und es nur daran scheitert, dass sich Bund und Länder mal wieder nicht darüber einigen können, wie diese Daten halt jetzt sinnvoll verwendet werden können, stattdessen schwaffelt die ins Sparen da halt irgendwelchen Unsinn. Und das ist halt irgendwie so ein Mismatch zwischen möglicher Lösung und möglicher Realität und dem, was tatsächlich passiert, der mich gerade so ein bisschen fertig macht, ehrlich gesagt.
Naja, also man muss zur Ehrenrettung vielleicht sagen, ich habe da ein paar Mails gekriegt von Leuten aus Gesundheitsämtern, die meinten, naja, wir haben da halt so eine Excel-Tabelle. Das ist halt der Stand auf dem. Ja, nee, ich will dich überhaupt nicht korrigieren an der Stelle. Ich will nur sagen, wir als IT-Techis haben halt mal grob gesehen.
Es gibt ein, es gibt ein System, das ist fertig.
Ja, ich weiß, du weißt, wer noch so ein fertiges System hat. Die Werbebranche, Stream-Datenbanken, alles open source, wunderbar. Gibt's, ja, kann man zusammenstöpseln, funktioniert. Big Data, irgendwie gibt's auch alles. Alerting auf Basis von Thresholds, gibt's auch alles. Also wir wissen halt, was es für Technik gibt, aber die Leute in den Behörden, das ist irgendein Typ, der da freiwillig mal irgendwas gebastelt hat, wenn es da überhaupt was gibt. Ansonsten machen die doch Fax.
Das ist nicht korrekt.
Machen die noch Fax?
Nein, das ist schlicht nicht korrekt. Das ist einfach schlicht falsch. Es gibt ein RKI-System, es ist fertig. Es ist ein System für das Reporting von Infektionskrankheiten. Dieses System wurde seit mehreren Jahren entwickeln. Es wird nur nicht eingesetzt, weil wir gerade hier eine beschissene Bund-Länder-Problematik haben, dass nämlich die Bundesländer und die einzelnen Kreise diese Software nicht einsetzen, die eigentlich da ist und verwendet werden könnte für exakt genau diesen Zweck. Und dafür habe ich genau kein Verständnis.
Ich auch nicht. Ich auch nicht. Aber es ist halt...
Und es hat nichts mit Technik zu tun, sondern es hat nur damit zu tun, dass irgendjemand eifersüchtig auf seinen Scheiß da ist.
Du, niemand ist eifersüchtig, will seine Excel-Tabelle behalten. Sondern das ist halt... Du kannst dir das vorstellen wie in so einer Schule. Die meisten wissen es einfach nicht, dass es diese Software gibt. Das ist nicht unbedingt böser Wille. Das ist wie in einer Schule, wo du sagst, wieso habt ihr denn hier nicht ordentlich? Und dann stellt sich raus, der Informatiklehrer hat in seiner Freizeit irgendwie ein Apache aufgesetzt. Das ist das bisherige System. Und so sieht das in den Gesundheitsbehörden auch aus, weil die eben, wie du es schon erwähnt hast, durch die Bund-Länder-Trennung so laufen, dass irgendwie das Land Berlin nicht mit dem Land Brandenburg redet, sondern jeder irgendwie seinen eigenen Scheiß macht. Und das führt dazu, dass wir am Wochenende überhaupt kein Reporting haben, weil die Behörden zu sind. Also auch eine Situation, wo ich mir nur an den Kopf fassen kann. Und das Robert Koch-Institut macht jetzt eine Interpolation aus den Daten und versucht, diese Gaps rauszurechnen. Ja, weil wir dann natürlich am Montag, wenn die Daten vom Wochenende kommen, einen Peak haben und so. Absurdeste Zustände. Das heißt, die Daten, die wir kriegen, sind alle mit irgendwie statistischen Modellen irgendwie zurück gerade geglättet. Es ist unfassbar. Ja, es ist unfassbar. Würde ich persönlich auch unserer Bundesregierung zulasten legen und nicht den einzelnen Ländern, weil die hätten ja sagen können, okay, Leute, kippert euch mal. Ja, hätte man ja machen können. Also in dem ist wichtig, hier ist die Software installiert, jetzt Punkt. Hätte man ja auch einfach mal machen können, oder?
Ja, es gibt sogar ein webbasiertes Reporting dafür. Sie hätten nicht mal Software benutzen müssen. Es würde einfach reichen, eine Adresse in, also sich einen Account zu besorgen in einer, ich meine, dieses System sieht scheiße aus. Es ist halt eine, sieht halt aus wie eine klassische IT-Fachanwendung. So, aber sie ist halt einfach da. Sie kann, man kann sie einfach verwenden. So, man kann da einfach seine Daten reintippen. So, und man braucht nicht mal spezielle Software dafür.
Aber dann verliert man die Hoheit über die Daten, wenn man die da reintippt.
Genau das ist das Problem. Und das ist halt genau das, worum es hier gerade geht. Dass halt einfach diese, also selbst in so einer Situation halt irgendwie nicht versucht wird, halt einfach mal irgendwie zu sagen, zentralisieren wir mal an dieser einen Stelle, wo es halt irgendwie tatsächlich sinnvoll nötig ist. Na ja.
Gut, auf der anderen Seite gab es jetzt gerade in den Nachrichten die Story, ich weiß nicht, bei der Süddeutschen, habe ich es glaube ich gesehen, haben sie irgendwie zurückgerechnet den ersten Covid-Fall. Irgendwie eine, wer sich da wann mit wem, konnte man rekonstruieren, obwohl wir diese Daten alle nicht haben. Also das heißt, es geht eigentlich.
Aber Leute losgegangen sind.
Ja natürlich, aber das finde ich ja nicht schlimm. Ja, aber das heißt prinzipiell geht es. Das wird nicht eine wichtige Erkenntnis an der Stelle. In einer See, in einem Ozean aus, oh mein Gott, was wird passieren? Wir wissen alle nichts, kann man sagen, es geht. Ja, wir wissen, es geht, denn es hat jemand gemacht. So nichts von dem, was wir hier gerade vor uns haben, ist irgendwie unlösbar oder geht halt nicht oder wir wissen nicht, wie es geht. Doch, doch, also das ist die, die, die meisten der, der tatsächlichen Probleme, die wir haben, sind lösbar. Und wir kennen sie und wir haben die Lösung sogar. Wir müssen sie nur mal einsetzen. Es ist völlig, völlig unnötig, dass wir hier alle in Furcht vor uns hin vegetieren.
Naja, also diese, diese Software vom AKI, demis, D-E-M-I-S und Können wir die Linkliste tun, wenn du möchtest. Können wir die Linkliste tun, genau.
Übrigens zu dem Nikotin würde ich gerne noch andeuten, dass es natürlich auch eine Studie in die Gegenrichtung gab. Die erste, die ich gesehen habe, war, da ging es um Italien. Da hat man nämlich festgestellt, es sind viel mehr Männer betroffen als Frauen. Und die hat man gesagt, okay, woran könnte das liegen? Und dann war so die erste Theorie, na, in Italien rauchen die Männer alle. So, und in China gab es eine ähnliche Theorie. Also das heißt, selbst wenn man jetzt die Studie malidiert, kann es trotzdem passieren, dass man zwei Studien hat, die sich widersprechen und die können trotzdem beide wahr sein.
Und der Punkt ist, es kann tatsächlich sogar sein, dass Rauchen, also tatsächlich das Konsumieren von verbranntem Tabak schädlich ist, aber der Konsum von Nikotin als Reinsubstanz, durch zum Beispiel Nikotinpflaster oder ähnliches, oder Kaugummi, tatsächlich hilft, ist immer noch im Bereich des Möglichen. Also muss man irgendwie...
Rufen wir aber nicht so auf, ja?
Rufen wir nicht so auf explizit, nicht so im Auge behalten, aber keine Handlungsanweisung draus ableiten. So, wie findet man dann aber eigentlich raus, ob so eine Studie jetzt eigentlich halt irgendwie seriös und sinnvoll ist, oder? Das ist halt so eine Aufgabe, die, wo man sagen muss, wenn man nicht Wissenschaftler eines bestimmten Fachgebiets ist, ist es... Gibt es Anhaltspunkte? Na, es gibt halt irgendwie sozusagen so, sowas wie so ein paar Checkpoints, die man da verwenden kann, um so einen Eindruck davon zu bekommen, ob diese Studie sinnvoll und relevant ist. Aber man kann, wenn man die nicht zu einer Einordnung in der Lage ist, was jetzt irgendwie die spezifischen, zum Beispiel biochemischen Zusammenhänge und so angeht, ist es häufig nicht so einfach, sich da halt ein Bild zu machen, was halt nicht komplett daneben liegt. Ich vergleiche das immer damit so, wenn Wissenschaftler über Technologie reden, sondern wenn Politiker über Technologie reden, zum Beispiel Politiker über 5G reden. Also wenn die halt so 5G hören, dann denken die, jetzt ist irgendwie so die Magic Silver Bullet Technologie, die irgendwie alles komplett neu macht. So und dann guckt man halt irgendwie als jemand, der in dieser Branche damit zu tun hat und weiß, wie halt diese Technologie funktioniert da rein und sagt sich so naja, wieso sie das da 5G rangerieben haben, kann ich so aus Marketing-Sicht nachvollziehen, weil sie halt irgendwie Geld für neue Infrastruktur haben wollten. In der Praxis ist 5G 4G, also halt LTE, das was wir ohnehin schon haben, wo halt auf der Funkseite, also an den Funkzellen, halt ein paar mehr neue Frequenzen dazukommen.
Aber auch erst in der Zukunft, noch nicht jetzt?
Na jetzt schon so ein paar, sind halt noch ein paar neue Frequenzblöcke, die halt aber in Bereichen, die halt eigentlich früher auch schon verwendet worden, im Wesentlichen, also nicht durchgehend, aber in Deutschland im Wesentlichen, wo die jetzt halt neu bestückt werden, dass neue Frequenzen halt erschlossen werden, damit man halt mehr Bandbreite durchkriegt. Und in der Praxis sind 4G und 5G Zellen eigentlich im Wesentlichen dasselbe, die arbeiten halt einfach unterschiedlichen Frequenzen. Häufig genug sind es sogar dieselben Antennen, mindestens dieselben Antennenstandorte. Das ändert sich halt erst, wenn die wirklich hohen Frequenzen dazu kommen, also dann hat es so die 30 Gigahertz, die dann halt, wie sich eher so wie Licht ausbreiten und von jeder Wand abgehalten werden. Aber die dürften selbst für die schlimmsten Wafies, also die Leute, die halt irgendwie von Strahlen Probleme bekommen, selbst denen wird es schwerfallen, sich bei diesen 30 Gigahertz bei niedrigen Leistungen einzureden, dass da irgendwas problematisch werden könnte. Anyway, der große nächste Schritt, das passiert, dass nämlich hinten bei den Telcos im Kern Sachen anders gebaut werden, als sie bei LTE momentan sind, der passiert erst irgendwann in der Zukunft. So was momentan passiert ist, real passiert bei den Telcos ist, dass die ihre existierende LTE-4G-Infrastruktur, also das, was sie heute sowieso schon den ganzen Tag benutzt, dass sie da neue Antennen dran schnallen, also neue Sendemasten dazu tun, die auf anderen Frequenzen ein bisschen an den Frequenzen funktionieren. Und dann nennt es sich 5G. Das heißt, auch aus der technischen Perspektive heraus ist dieses 5G macht irgendwie unser Immunsystem kaputt und dann kommen die Viren mit den Quanten, Nano, Dotzner und so. Dieser ganze Quatsch hat halt überhaupt nichts mit der Realität zu tun. Und das Problem ist halt, dass...
Die Nano-Dotz haben dich echt erwischt, oder?
Die haben mich wirklich erwischt. Das Problem ist halt, dass man, wenn man sich nicht wirklich mal in so ein Gebiet eine Weile reingenerdet hat, steht man, wenn man so relativ spezialisierte Studien, also gerade zur Medikamentenwirkung, versucht zu interpretieren oder so zu Metabolismusfunktionen, steht man so ähnlich da wie halt so ein Politiker vor dem 5G. Man redet da halt so über so Dinge so und im Detail hat man aber nicht wirklich Ahnung von, sondern wiederholt halt nur irgendwelche Schlagworte. Ist halt ungefähr so wie am Anfang der Epidemie, wie halt plötzlich alle zu Epideminologen wurden, obwohl sie überhaupt nicht mal Basis Ahnung von Statistik hatten und wie halt irgendwie Ausbreitung funktioniert. Ja, ich meine, wenn es gut lief, haben sie mal irgendwie Plague Incorporated gespielt. Dann haben sie zumindest mal so einen groben Eindruck, einen groben Eindruck davon, wie es funktioniert. Aber halt so, da muss man halt einfach echt ein bisschen aufpassen. Also so die Überschätzung der eigenen Kompetenz bei irgendwie solchen Themen ist immer ein bisschen problematisch. Also meine grobe Heuristik ist so, mit dem, was ich mir so selber rauslese aus Studien, was ich so interpretiere und so, kann ich möglicherweise Entscheidungen für mich treffen. Also kann ich sagen, okay, was ich daraus folgere, hat für mein persönliches Leben jetzt noch mal ein relativ niedriges Risiko oder ist keine besonders große Mühe oder ist halt irgendwie eine Sache, die ich halt einfach machen kann oder ist mir das Risiko wert, weil ich einschätze das. Aber macht das bitte nicht für andere. Na, das ist halt irgendwie daraus, dass ihr irgendwas so glaubt, halb verstanden zu haben. Handlungsanweisung oder Handlungserwartung für andere rauszulesen ist halt vollständig unangemessen. Also irgendwie daraus zu sagen, so ich hab das jetzt irgendwie so und so verstanden, du musst es genauso verstehen. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt alle zusammen dies oder jenes tun oder dies oder jenes nehmen, ist halt kompletter Quatsch. So ihr könnt für euch selber versuchen, sinnvolle Folgerungen zu ziehen und irgendwie für euch selber halt irgendwie zu verstehen und aus diesem Verstehen vorsichtig möglicherweise auch Handlungen ableiten, aber bitte nicht für andere. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Der wichtigste Bias, also Bias ist so eine, wenn es nicht gleich verteilt ist im Allgemeinen, oder eine Einflussnahme, auf die man achten muss. Die wichtigsten Bias ist, der allerwichtigste betrifft euch selbst, das ist der Confirmation Bias. Dass ihr irgendwie mit einer Vorannahme irgendwo rangeht und eine Studie findet, die das bestätigt und dann glaubt, jetzt ist die Sache ja klar. Das ist leider, liegt in der menschlichen Natur, dass die Leute Sachen, die ihre Position bestätigen, für profunder halten als Sachen, die ihre bestehende Position nicht bestätigen. Und dazu kommt im Internetzeitalter, dass wir eben nicht alle Studien lesen und dann die einfach, finde ich, wichtig halten, die uns widerlegen, sondern wir sehen überhaupt nur die Studien, die uns bestätigen, weil wir nämlich nach denen gegoogelt haben. Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt sozusagen wissen wollt oder mit der Fragestellung rangeht, hilft Vitamin D gegen Covid und ihr googelt Vitamin D und Covid, dann findet ihr halt genau die Studien, die sagen, hey, Vitamin D ist total geil. Ach, apropos, wir verkaufen hier Vitamin D-Tabletten. Das ist das schlimmste Problem, was ihr haben werdet, wenn ihr versucht, irgendwelche Studien rauszufinden. Man muss sich wirklich hinstellen und gucken, ob es auch Gegenpositionen gibt. Vielleicht Leute, die die Studie zitiert haben.
Wobei die Gegenpositionen häufiger einfach nur andere Pillen verkaufen wollen.
Genau, das kommt dazu. Also im Internet ist noch mal verstärkend, dass wir als Laien eben auch gar nicht entscheiden können. Ist das jetzt eine ordentliche Studie oder ist das sagen wir mal irgendein Open Access-Scheiß? Also es gibt ja da im Internet auch durchaus...
Access muss nicht scheiß sein, ne?
Nein, aber es gibt im Internet Sites, die sozusagen so tun, als seien sie ein Journal und da kannst du dein Scheiß hinschicken und dann zahlst du denen eine Gebühr und dann veröffentlichen sie das und tun so, als sei das jetzt akademisch wertvoll veröffentlicht.
Tatsächlich passiert auch seriöse Wissenschaft mittlerweile so, ne? Also mach keinen Fehler.
Nein, ich will nicht sagen, dass es immer scheiß ist, aber das heißt, dass wenn ich jetzt irgendwas google und ich finde das auf irgendeiner Site, also z.B. archive.org mit ARXIV ist so eine Site, die eben Preprints veröffentlicht. Und da kann sozusagen jeder alles hochladen. Das heißt, dass die die Site irgendwas angenommen hat, heißt halt nichts. Das ist wie YouTube, da kann auch jeder irgendwie alles hochladen. Und dass diese Art von Einschätzungsmöglichkeit fehlt eben uns als Laien komplett. Daher würde ich eigentlich grundsätzlich davor warnen wollen, den Versuch zu unternehmen, irgendwelche Studien verstehen zu wollen. Lieber ein paar Studien rausnehmen und damit zum Arzt gehen und den fragen der Arzt deines Vertrauens, ob man gerade irgendwie krass vom Weg abgekommen ist oder nicht. Und wahrscheinlich wird dein Arzt das auch nicht wissen, weil es irgendwelche Spezial-Detail-Sachen sind, die du da gefunden haben wirst. Also die Beurteilung ist inzwischen eben so schwierig, dass selbst jemand, der sich da, der promoviert hat, auf dem Gebiet nicht unbedingt in der Lage sein wird, jedes Paper lesen und verstehen zu können. Aber es gibt so zwei, drei Sachen, auf die kann man trotzdem achten. Eine ordentliche medizinische Studie zu der Wirksamkeit von einem Medikament ist eine Doppelblind-Studie. Das bedeutet, man hat eine möglichst zufällig ausgewählte Teilmenge der Bevölkerung. Da gibt es auch nochmal Regeln, wie man die jetzt genau so bestimmt, dass jede Minorität irgendwie vertreten ist und dass man am Ende rausrechnen kann, dass die Verteilung stimmt. Man braucht also eine bestimmte Anzahl, das ist auch schwierig, wie groß die jetzt genau sein muss. Und dann teilt man das in der Mitte auf und sagt, die linke Hälfte kriegt ein Placebo und die rechte Hälfte kriegt das Medikament, was wir testen wollen. Und wir machen das aber so, dass auch der Arzt, der das verabreicht, dem Patienten, dass auch der nicht weiß, ob er gerade das Placebo oder die richtige Pille verabreicht, damit er nicht mit seiner Körpersprache kommunizieren kann. Also das ist die Mindestanforderung an eine ordentliche Studie.
Nein, nein, das ist der Goldstandard.
Naja, also der Rest, würde ich sagen, ist keine ordentliche Studie.
Nee, der Punkt ist halt, es gibt natürlich schon noch andere Studien, weil du hast nicht mal Zeit, also jetzt gerade, was jetzt irgendwie diesen Covid-Kram angeht, Naja, Schlachtfest ist halt einfach ein, ist halt andere Standardgebnisse anzudenken. Es ist halt nicht die Zeit, halt irgendwie eine ordentliche Doppelblind-Studie mit irgendwie mindestens 1000 Leuten zu machen, die halt irgendwie nach möglichst großer Verteilung der genetischen, ethischen und Altersvoraussetzungen irgendwie gemacht worden sind. So was ja halt eigentlich so der, ja, also die, ja, das, was man eigentlich gerne haben möchte. Und so eine Studien dauern ja halt auch ewige Zeiten. Also die sind halt irgendwie mit so drei Jahren, ist man da schon irgendwie schnell dabei.
Und ja, und ist halt gerade noch mal länger, wenn es überhaupt jemand versucht.
Ja, und immer noch länger. Und dann müssen halt wenigstens die Daten dafür vorliegen. Sinnvollerweise oder jemand hat es noch mal einen leicht anderen Fokus gemacht. Dann gibt es halt auch das Problem, was ist eigentlich die Frage, die die Studie beantworten will? Ist das Studiendesign dafür überhaupt geeignet? Hat man möglicherweise Daten aus einer anderen Studie genommen und neu interpretiert? Dann gibt es halt diese solche, dieser sogenannten Meta-Studien, die ich immer besonders suspekt finde, wo Leute halt irgendwelche Studien, die eigentlich völlig andere Fragen beantworten wollten, nehmen und dann daraus versuchen halt durch Interpretationen und statistische Analyse eine ganz andere Frage zu beantworten. Diese Meta-Studien zeichnen sich in der Regel dadurch aus, dass sie sehr selektiv dabei sind, welche Studien sie überhaupt in die Meta-Studie aufnehmen. Also wenn ihr Meta-Studie lest, da bin ich irgendwie an dem Punkt, wo ich sage, wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz viel Zeit habe, mal zu gucken, was halt irgendwie da der, das Design und welche Studien sie reingenommen haben und was, welche Grundstücke sie abgelehnt haben und so weiter und so fort, um die reinzunehmen. Wenn ich da nicht viel Zeit für habe, dann ignore ich diese Studie halt in der Regel. Typischerweise sind diese Meta-Studien halt auch so genannten Debunking-Studien, die dann halt immer gleichzeitig hingehen und sagen so, ja, wir wollen mal nachweisen, dass XYZ sowieso nicht funktioniert und totaler Quatsch ist. Und sind das aber vom Design her vom Design her halt völlig fahrlässig und so. Also da gebe ich gerade nicht besonders viel drauf auf diesen Kran. Interessant ist halt letzten Endes halt die Frage, was tut ihr eigentlich persönlich in eurem Alltag so? Und da sind wir jetzt gerade in dieser Phase von diesen sogenannten Lockerungen. Und da, also jetzt so für meinen Mindset, muss halt jeder für sich, glaube ich, irgendwie da für sich irgendwie raussortieren. Aber für meinen Mindset ist so, es wird halt eine zweite Welle geben. Die Frage ist halt nur, wann? So, wenn die Lockerungen jetzt halt zu weit gehen, dann wird das halt irgendwann wahrscheinlich im Juli wieder soweit sein, wenn sie halt irgendwie okay sind. Also wenn sozusagen die Ansteckungsbeschleunigung jetzt zum Beispiel durch Faktoren wie Sonnenlicht und Luftfeuchtigkeit im Sommer, also zur Erklärung Sonnenlicht, es hilft gegen Viren, hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit hilft offensichtlich auch gegen Viren.
Nee, nicht gegen den Virus, aber es kann sich dann halt nicht mehr...
Ja, gegen die Verbreitung, genau. Das kann halt sein, dass das dazu führt, dass wir halt im Sommer weniger Stress haben. Aber es wird halt eine zweite Welle geben. So und die Frage ist dann halt, wie geht man damit um? Wie sind sinnvolle Maßnahmen für Einschränkungen? So und wir haben halt momentan das Problem, dass größere Teile der Wirtschaft halt einfach komplett im Eimer sind. Und je länger die halt aus sind, desto größer wird halt auch einfach die Anzahl der Spinner werden, die da draußen sind und sagen so, hier Regierung, ihr habt mir mein Leben kaputt gemacht für eine Krankheit, die vielleicht irgendwie jetzt gar nicht so schlimm ist, wie immer behauptet wird. Und diese Einschätzung, was ist jetzt die Abwägung des gesellschaftlichen Schadens? Wie rechnet man Lebensjahre auf von Leuten, die dann halt irgendwie jetzt früher an Corona sterben oder Covid-19 sterben, versus irgendwie, was ist der gesellschaftliche Schaden oder auch der sonstige Schaden, der halt entsteht, weil zum Beispiel mehr häusliche Gewalt auftritt, weil die Menschen halt irgendwie ihren Bildungsweg nicht weitergehen können, weil sie weniger Geld verdienen, deswegen irgendwie bestimmte Chancen nicht haben, weil irgendwie Kinder zu Hause bleiben müssen und deswegen in ihrer Entwicklung zurückfallen und so weiter. Also diese ganzen sonstigen Schäden, die jetzt durch diese Maßnahmen entstehen, die halt abzuwägen gegen die Risiken, die halt durch die Krankheit selber kommen, ist halt echt keine einfache Aufgabe. Und da kann man auch sehr unterschiedliche Ansicht dazu sein, was jetzt halt irgendwie angemessen und was nicht angemessen ist. Und das ist halt so eine Aufgabe, die ich auch tatsächlich nicht gerne haben wollen würde. Also diese Entscheidung ist halt am Ende eine inneren politische. Also eine, wo man halt sagen muss, okay, Experten geben halt Input. Aber ein Virologe sagt natürlich, wir müssen jetzt hier halt einfach mal Lockdown machen, bis wir irgendwie bei nur Infektionen sind. Und der Ökonom daneben sagt, dann ist halt schön, dann haben wir halt nur Infektionen, aber wir haben auch keine Wirtschaft mehr. Und der Psychologe daneben sagt dann so, naja, klar, können wir jetzt halt noch irgendwie drei Monate Lockdown machen, irgendwie vollständiges Kontaktverbot einführen. Dann haben wir halt leider nur eine komplette Generation von Leuten, die halt einfach ein bisschen komisch im Kopf sind und die dann halt entsprechende Folgekosten generieren. So, und irgendwo dazwischen muss man dann halt irgendwie so eine Balance finden, die halt auch echt nicht so einfach zu finden.
Naja, also es geht nicht nur darum, dass Leute komisch im Kopf sind, sondern es geht auch um eine Selbstmordrate, die natürlich hochgeht, wenn man den Leuten ihre Existenzen kaputtmacht.
Also gerade ist die Selbstmordrate erstaunlich niedrig, interessanterweise. Also niedriger als sonst.
Aber wie ist es, schön Sommer und Sonne helfen gegen Depression?
Nee, weil tatsächlich die, also die wahrscheinlichste Theorie, ist, dass ein häufiger Grund für Suizide ist, wenn Leute das Gefühl haben, dass sich nichts mehr ändert und sie keine Möglichkeit für Veränderungen haben. Wenn jetzt aber sowieso die ganze Welt sich ändert, also sozusagen alle Umstände sowieso infrage stehen, kann man auch noch mal ein bisschen abwarten, was jetzt eigentlich passiert. Okay, ja, frag mich, finde ich gut. Interessante Theorie, aber in dem Augenblick, wo der Lockdown dann halt quasi zur neuen Normalität wird und sich daran nichts ändert, geht natürlich dann halt im Zweifel die Suizidrate hoch. Also die Anzahl, also die Menge an Depressionen, auch die schweren Depressionen geht gerade hoch. Und wir haben auch noch das Phänomen, das würde uns interessieren, liebe Hörerinnen, wenn ihr in der Branche arbeitet. Wir haben anekdotische Berichte darüber, dass in der Psychologie, im Psychiatrie, es Mangel an bestimmten Medikamenten gibt, die halt Menschen mit psychologischen oder psychiatrischen Krankheiten bekommen. Ich hab das verschiedentlich erzählt bekommen, aber das ist jetzt eher so anekdotisch. Und uns würde interessieren, ob ihr ähnliche Dinge auch hört, also dass bestimmte Medikamente nicht oder schwer verfügbar sind. Deswegen Leute auf andere Medikamente umgestellt werden oder gar keine Medikamente bekommen, weil die Praxen geschlossen sind und so weiter. Und dass auch Leute natürlich, die jetzt irgendwie neu durch die Umstände zafte psychologische Probleme bekommen, einfach schlicht keine Therapieplätze oder auch keine Gesprächsplätze bekommen, weil die ohnehin schon sehr, sehr angespannte Situation in den Gebieten jetzt natürlich noch sehr viel angespannter ist. Was wiederum auch erklären könnte, warum auf diesen Corona-Demonstrationen so viele Leute sind, die halt, naja, sagen wir mal, von professioneller Hilfe vielleicht noch profitieren könnten, die sie aber vielleicht nicht kriegen. Das wäre eine Theorie, die wir gerne mal ein bisschen nachgehen würden. Also wenn ihr da okay first-hand berichtet zu habt, wenn ihr in der Branche arbeitet, dann schreibt uns doch mal, das würde uns interessieren.
Ja, ich habe noch zwei Sachen, die ich gerne erwähnen würde. Wir haben jetzt ein bisschen über Studien geredet und dass man da irgendwie keine guten Karten hat, wenn man selbst verstehen will, was da jetzt zu folgern ist. Ich würde gerne noch mal explizit davor warnen, Journalismus über medizinische Studien ernst zu nehmen, weil das ist in über 90 Prozent der Fälle kompletter Bullshit, was die schreiben. Und zwar insbesondere, wenn die Schlagzeile als Frage formuliert ist, sowas wie hilft Nikotin gegen Covid? Ja, dann könnt ihr das direkt irgendwie skippen. Das ist so ein häufiger Trick im Journalismus, wenn man irgendwie ein paar Seiten füllen muss, aber nichts in der Hand hat, dann stellt man irgendeine offensichtliche Frage. Die Antwort ist im Allgemeinen nein. Ja, aber es ist eben Journalisten haben das selbe.
Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Genau. Aber Journalisten haben da halt auch keine besseren Werkzeuge oder mehr Erfahrung als ihr, wenn es darum geht, irgendwelche wissenschaftlichen Studien auszuwerten. Und die haben im Allgemeinen sogar noch weniger Zeit als ihr. Ja, also manche natürlich schon. Es gibt Ausnahmen. Jetzt vielleicht irgendwie Ärzteblatt oder so, wird man schon an der Stelle lesen können. Aber wenn jetzt der Fokus irgendwie auf eine Studie verweist oder Sputnik oder so, dann würde ich mir direkt klemmen.
Ja, also ich würde mir einfach angucken, welche fachliche Befähigung hat denn eigentlich der Journalist oder die Journalistin. Es gibt tatsächlich auch bei den großen Medien durchaus Wissenschaftsjournalisten, die eine entsprechende wissenschaftliche Grundausbildung haben und durchaus in der Lage sind, zumindest noch mal die Rahmenparameter von so einer Studie sinnvoll zu interpretieren und zu hinterfragen oder gar möglicherweise sogar in dem Fachgebiet unterwegs sind. Das ist allerdings nicht so häufig.
Die Ausnahme ist es, ne?
Genau, ja, ich würde sagen, zumindest bei vielen Medien die Ausnahme. Und häufig ist es dann eben auch so, dass deren Expertise in einem anderen Gebiet liegt und sie dann versuchen, einen Transfer zu machen von dem, wo sie sich auskennen und wo halt ihre Expertise liegt in andere Gebiete, mit denen sie dann halt irgendwie qua irgendwie Redaktionskonferenzbeschluss sich jetzt halt beschäftigen müssen.
Das ist besonders krass, wenn es Ökonomen sind. Dann würd ich generell irgendwie direkt in die Tonne.
Ja, da muss man dann sehr aufpassen.
Ja, aber so Muster, nach denen ihr gucken könnt, ob ihr irgendwas ernst nehmen, also direkt irgendwie in der Vorauswahl schon rausschmeißen könnt, sind so, wenn die Schlagzeile eine Frage ist oder wenn da so Sachen gemacht werden, wie so und so konnte nicht ausschließen das. Das ist eine Null-Aussage. Ja, das kann direkt in die Tonne. Das kommt so gut wie nie vor, dass man irgendwas wirklich ausschließen kann, denn die gesamte Welt ist wahrscheinlich ganz passiert. Oder so Sachen wie, ich sag mal, die WHO befürchtet so und so, so und so. Das heißt es halt nicht, sondern das kann auch einfach heißen, die WHO konnte es nicht ausschließen und daraus macht der Journalist jetzt einen irgendwie Befürchtung, weil sich das halt besser verkauft. Also in Zweifelsfall immer Vorsicht bei Fragen und so Suggestivgeschichten und Studien kann man gerne mal zu lesen versuchen, aber habt im Hinterkopf, dass ihr wahrscheinlich keine Ahnung habt und das gerade falsch lest. Das sollte immer eure Herangehensweise prägen, wenn ihr versucht, irgendwelche fachfremden wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten zu lesen.
Ja, ansonsten, wir haben uns nicht über diese Corona-App unterhalten.
Haben wir glaube ich auch bald keinen Bock mehr, oder?
Nee, ich glaube, da können wir jetzt einfach mal warten, bis sie fertig ist. Und dann unterhalten wir uns darüber, wenn sie fertig ist.
Und dann baschen wir alle. Das ist immer die einfachste Position.
Ja, aber ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt auf Default-Baschen gehen, sondern eher eine sachliche. Weil ich meine, damit kennen wir uns immerhin aus. Also das heißt zu sagen, was ein Thema, wo wir beide irgendwie Expertise haben, irgendwie Softwarequalität und irgendwie Funk- und Mobilapplikation. Das heißt, das können wir uns dann ja vielleicht mal irgendwie vornehmen, wenn die draußen ist, dass wir dann darüber reden, was da eigentlich passiert. Weil momentan ist halt auch so, dass einfach so viel entwickelt und so viel Konzeptarbeit ändert sich da immer wieder. Also wenn ihr euch fragt, warum wir jetzt dazu nichts gesagt haben, das ist halt einfach noch nicht fertig. Und deshalb quatscht jetzt da irgendwie über irgendwie Dinge zu diskutieren, wo sich die Konzepte einfach auch so quasi im Wochentakt irgendwie an relativ interessanten Stellen ändern. Schauen wir dann mal, wenn es so weit ist.
Also ich finde es überhaupt wichtig, dass man drauf achtet, nicht nur bei sich selbst festzustellen, ich habe ja gar nicht die Ahnung, die nötig wäre, um das hier gerade zu verstehen, sondern sich auch bei anderen zu fragen, so kann er das eigentlich beurteilen. Es gab da jetzt gerade einen Fall, der mich sehr geärgert hat. Da gab es dann irgendeine Lockdown-Skeptik-Webseite, die hat irgendwie geschrieben, ja der Quellcode für das Modell, was die Briten benutzt haben in ihrer Vorhersage vom Imperial College.
Das Infektionsmodell.
Das Infektionsmodell, womit die halt rum simuliert haben, wo dann diese apokalyptischen Vorhersagen herkamen, die letztendlich ja auch dazu geführt haben, dass die britische Regierung eingelenkt hat und jetzt doch Lockdown versucht, wenn auch nicht sonderlich geschickt. Also jedenfalls, der Quellcode davon ist offen, was relativ selten ist im wissenschaftlichen Umfeld, weil die meisten Leute sich einfach schämen auch für den Code. Das kann man vielleicht auch einfach mal sagen. Der meiste akademische Code ist richtig doll scheiße. Der wird halt von Leuten, die noch in der Ausbildung sind, irgendwie zusammengefrickelt, bis irgendwie das Ergebnis für diesen einen Spezialfall stimmt. Und sie möchten halt nicht, dass Leute sehen, was sie da mal gehackt haben, weil das halt alles gruseliger alter Scheiß-Fortran-Code ist, der man vielleicht irgendwie... Also in diesem Fall ist es kein Fortran, sondern C-Code, aber man sieht ihm halt an, dass es mal Fortran-Code war, den irgendein armes Schwein oder vielleicht eine Software.
Hast du da reingeguckt?
Ich hab da mal reingeguckt. Aber es ist halt der gesamte Corpus, den es so gibt, an Simulationssoftware sieht halt so aus. Es gibt so ein paar alte Libraries, die halt aus den Uhrzeiten, der Urschlamm der Simulationsinformatik und darauf basieren halt diese ganzen Simulationsgeschichten und das sieht furchtbar aus, ja. Das ist aber immer so. Und deswegen der Code hier, der sieht zwar auch furchtbar aus, aber jetzt nicht schlimmer als andere.
Du hast versucht, die Claims zu verifizieren, die da liegen?
Ach, die Claims haben mich besonders geärgert, weil der Typ halt damit eröffnete, er hätte ja 30 Jahre bei Microsoft gearbeitet. So als Programmierer. Und jetzt maßt er sich halt an, irgendwie diesen Code zu lesen und zu sagen, ja, das stimmt ja alles nicht, ja. Und eine der Beschwerden war z.B., wenn man die Simulationen mehrfach laufen lässt, dann kommen verschiedene Werte raus. Ja, so ist das bei Simulationen. Ja, da hast du halt irgendwie, hast halt Regeln, die müssen nicht deterministisch sein. Also es gibt da...
Sind da Zufallswerte drin?
Ja, natürlich ist da Zufall drin, klar. Du willst ja Zufall drin haben. Das ist ja keine, ich will die Welt nachstellen, sondern ich will wissen, was kann denn alles passieren? Und das ReadMe zu dem Code sagt, führ das mal mehrfach aus und gucke, wie sich das entwickelt. Ja, du willst den Trend, willst du wissen, nicht? Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, morgen wird die Welt so sein. Ist nicht die Art von Simulation. Die gibt es auch, aber die scheitert an anderen Sachen. So und...
Also das ist halt der sinnvolle Weg, irgendwie das zu benutzen, ist halt, du lässt es halt irgendwie 500 mal laufen und dann nimmst du halt den Minen von den Modellen oder sowas.
Ja, und du kannst gucken, wie weit die auseinanderlaufen. Also es gibt da schon verschiedene Sachen, die man gucken kann. Aber es gibt halt so ein paar Sachen, die dir offensichtlich überhaupt nicht verstanden hatte, der Typ, der das kritisiert hat, nämlich, was es für Probleme mit Floating-Point-Arithmetic gibt. Das ist das, was man im Rechner benutzt, um Nachkommazahlen zu verarbeiten. Und da gibt es halt inhärente Probleme, nämlich zum Beispiel Rundungsfehler. Und die Rundungsfehler, die sind einfach Teil des Feldes, in dem du dich bewegst. Man rechnet da nicht mit unendlicher Genauigkeit. Und in solchen Simulationen hast du noch das Problem, dass die sich halt zusammen addieren können, die Rundungsfehler und dass man deswegen im Setup seiner Simulation darauf achtet, dass das nicht außer außer Rand und Band läuft, der Fehleranteil an dem Ergebnis. Aber das ist eine Sache, die man hätte gucken können. Aber soweit kam der halt nicht. Der hat halt gesagt, ja wieso, da kommt jetzt hier, ich hab's zweimal laufen lassen, da kommt was anderes raus. Das ist unwissenschaftlich, ja so auf dem Niveau. Und wenn man jetzt überhaupt keine Ahnung von Simulationen hat, dann liest man sich das vielleicht durch und denkt, hey, das klingt erst mal nicht doof, was der da sagt. Ja doch, doch, klingt doof. Wenn man sich ein bisschen auskennt, klingt es halt doch doof. Ja, und dieses Problem, da hab ich jetzt halt das Glück, dass ich schon mal eine Simulationscode gesehen hab und das deswegen beurteilen kann. Aber das ärgert mich halt, weil das halt auch tausende andere Leute sehen, die das nicht haben. Und die denken jetzt halt, oh, ey, das ist alles auf Sand gebaut. Und das mag ja stimmen, unabhängig davon jetzt. Aber das ist halt keine Diets dafür, sondern diese Simulationscode, sie fällt aus, wie die Simulationscode eben aussieht. Na ja.
Na gut, aber das ist halt ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass das halt, obwohl es halt in einzelnen Aspekten halt irgendwie Bullshit ist, also beziehungsweise schlecht ist, wie zum Beispiel halt der Code in dieser Simulation, dass das halt nicht der valide Kritikpunkt daran ist. Sondern der valide Kritikpunkt ist halt...
Den haben sie gar nicht geguckt, weil sie nicht wussten, wo man gucken soll.
Genau, da waren sie, soweit kam sie gar nicht.
Na ja. Also aber ich denke mal, das muss man im Kopf behalten und insbesondere muss man es im Kopf behalten, wenn man fachfremde Literatur liest. Dass ich, ich kann jetzt nicht, vielleicht, wenn ich Glück habe, kann ich irgendwie den Worten folgen, ja, was der da sagt, aber das Framework, um das beurteilen zu können, ob das jetzt ordentlich war oder nicht, das habe ich überhaupt nicht. Insofern, also, ich finde es auch eine gute Idee, wenn man, wenn es jeder mal versucht, so ein paar wissenschaftliche Studien zu lesen, aber geht mal nicht davon aus, dass ihr da irgendwas sinnvoll verstanden haben werdet am Ende. Das ist eher so eine irgendwie persönliches Wachstum Geschichte, ja, dass ich irgendwie versuche, ein besserer Mensch zu werden, indem ich mehr Input reinziehe oder so, aber das ist jetzt nicht, ich lese mir eine Studie durch und dann weiß ich, wie die Welt funktioniert, so ist das nicht.
Ja, man kann sich halt natürlich in so ein Fachgebiet auch reinlernen, also ist ja nicht so, dass man akzeptieren muss, dass man da unwissend ist. Nur sollte man halt nicht glauben, dass es mit den Wikipedia-Artikeln und Pirate-Forum gelesen, gelesen, getan ist, sondern wenn man sich halt Expertise in einem Gebiet aufbauen will, dann ist das halt eine substanzielle Menge Arbeit und selbst da erkennt man die Leute, wo man halt das Vertrauen haben kann, dass sie da relativ viel Zeit reingesteckt haben, darin, dass sie halt relativ bescheiden sind. Also, dass sie halt klar sagen, so ich weiß es nicht so genau, ich hab mich hier auch nur irgendwie zwei, drei Wochen lang reingenerdet. So halt, also das ist halt so, dieses herangehen zu sagen, ich versuche meinen Beitrag und meiner Art und Weise, damit umzugehen, halt klarzustellen und zu sagen, okay, ich bin vielleicht jetzt nicht blöde und ich hab mich halt irgendwie damit beschäftigt, aber eben halt auch mehr auch nicht so, ne, und wie zum Beispiel Pavel. Pavel hat halt irgendwie diese interessante Statistikrechnung gemacht, um halt aus diesen Bullshit-Daten vom RKI, die halt hier unter all diesen beschriebenen Problemen des Reportings leiden, halt sowas Ähnliches wie einen sinnvollen Risikofaktor rauszudestillieren und der sagt aber auch, okay, ich hab da eigentlich keine Ahnung von alles, wovon ich Ahnung habe, ist halt matte, das hab ich mein ganzes Leben gemacht, ich kann halt Statistik machen und ich kann halt irgendwie feststellen, wenn Daten Quatsch sind, weil sie halt inkonsistent sind und ich kann versuchen, das irgendwie auszugleichen und irgendwie daraus halt irgendwie was Sinnvolles zu machen. Aber mehr verspreche ich jetzt hier halt auch nicht. Und da erkennt man Leute dran, mit denen man sich auseinandersetzen kann, Leute, die sich hinstellen und keine vorherige Expertise in diesem Feld haben und sich dann hinstellen und sagen, hier, ich weiß es jetzt alles und so ist es und da ist vorne und irgendwie, ich hab ein Video auf YouTube gesehen und das hat mir die Welt erklärt, da kann man dann auch getrost seine Zeit mit was anderem verbringen.
Ich würde noch hinzufügen wollen, dass selbst wenn man sich wo rein nerdet, man immer noch die Gefahr hat, sich in so einen Realitätstunnel zu begeben, weil man eben Selection Bias hat. Also man wählt die Sachen, mit denen man sich jetzt beschäftigt, aus und kriegt aber den Gegenwind gar nicht mit. Man kriegt gar nicht mit, die die Fehler um einen rum, die anderen, die die Kollegen im Studium gemacht hätten, die kriegt man halt nicht mit, sondern nur die eigenen Fehler. Das heißt, das ist immer noch schlechter, selbst wenn man jetzt fast unendlich Zeit investiert, um sich in irgendein Gebiet reinzunörden, ist es immer noch schlechter, als wenn man das mit Kollegen zusammen ordentlich studiert hat und in einer Gruppe. Insofern immer schön, behaltet euch das Gefühl, keine Ahnung zu haben. Daran erkennt man den, der Ahnung hat, dass er das nicht so tut, als wüsste er, was man da redet.
Ja. Na gut.
So, eine relativ kurze Sendung diesmal, aber wir haben ja auch, kloppen ja auch viel zu. Wir wollten ja auch nur, eigentlich wollten wir nur kurz was sagen.
Wir wollten ja nur kurz darüber reden, wie man versucht, nicht Pech zu haben beim Selberdenken. In diesem Sinne wünschen wir euch irgendwie geistige und körperliche Gesundheit.
Genau, haltet durch.
Es geht ja jetzt mittlerweile auch wieder. Versucht irgendwie insbesondere kurz darüber nachzudenken, was ihr wisst darüber, wie in welchen Situationen die Ansteckungsgefahr am größten ist. Ich sag mal so mein Haupt-Pief mit diesen Lockerungen sind gerade Fitnessstudios, wo ich so echt nicht verstehe, was das jetzt eigentlich soll. Weil es gibt ja eigentlich nichts Schlimmeres als Menschen, die in Innenräumen in relativ geringem Abstand sich körperlich intensiv betätigen. Also da würde mich nicht wundern, wenn wir dann demnächst Fitnessstudio-Infektionscluster in Hessen, was glaube ich, wo die Fitnessstudios wieder aufmachen dürfen, haben. Was ich echt nicht verstanden habe, da standen die Leute eine Nachtsschlange, damit sie irgendwie gleich wieder trainieren können. Man kann auch so schön Sport draus machen. Anyway, bleibt gesund, geistig und körperlich. Versucht euch nicht auf YouTube zu radikalisieren. Facebook ignorieren ist auch immer eine gute Idee.
Nutzt die Zeit, um euren Horizont zu erweitern, nicht um eure bestehenden Positionen zu bestätigen.
Genau. Und tatsächlich auch mal so ein paar Tage News Abstinenz ist auch eine echt gute Sache für den Kopf, kann ich bestätigen.
Ja, ich kriege dann immer böse Nails, wenn ich bei einem Wochenende lang nichts blogge. Ja, was ist los, lebst du noch?
Du bist ja da auch in deiner Verantwortung. Na gut, in diesem Sinne, dann bis zum nächsten Mal.